committee to
order requir to a
stat as chair of the house
Judiciary uh
oh Ned you have to you have to speak
into your
microphone I am
sorry you didn't Begin by saying can you
hear me you see that was your problem
that that must that must be the
difference
all right as chair of the house
Judiciary Committee I find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 Pur into executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing of bills referred to the
Judiciary Committee executive session on
pending legislation may be held although
I'm not intending to do that today
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by Zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules in RSA 91a
right to noaw anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS l g. state. n. Us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
reschedule we do have a staff member who
is participating today and that is
Jennifer for our committee
researcher she won't be actually
participating in the meeting but will be
monitoring the meeting please note that
all votes that are taken during the
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
we'll begin the meeting by taking roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also State whether
there is anyone in the room with them
during the meeting which is required
under the right to no
law and I'll begin by saying I'm Ned
Gordon I'm at my house in Bristol New
Hampshire and my wife may be in and out
of the room at times Mr clerk would you
call a
role yes Mr chairman it's my pleasure to
do so uh representative with clain is
not here that right
don't see
him
representative good morning if you can
hear me I am actually in my mobile
office today for at least the first hour
listening and taking care of a virgin
business I am currently in Belmont I
will go to Tilton and then back to
Belmont to my home office I'll be there
by 10 o'clock and I'm
alone thank you representative weler is
here now 208 he's
alone representative
Alexander representative
Alexander told me he had the
word representative
rice representative
sober I'm here in my home office in
Guilford by
myself representative
green representative
green must be exhausted for the
week representative Kelly I'm here alone
in Temple with my dog
representative
Taj representative
charier
good morning I'm here in my home office
in
Belmont I am
alone thank you representative
Smith um good morning I'm alone in
Durham representative bur and good
morning I am alone and I'm in West Milan
representative
or representative oron representative
Oregon is probably at the executive
committee meeting I'm missing this
morning
chair representative
dorenzo good morning I'm here in my home
office in New Market and I'm
alone representative
Chase Rollinsford in my home with my
cats representative Kenny good morning
I'm here and Durham alone remage may be
through the room throughout the day
thank you repres restive lley good
morning I'm here in Manchester with my
husband at
home representative
mcth representative
mcth representative paage morning I'm in
exor in my home office but children in
the house thank
you representative Simpson
good morning I'm at home in exitor and
I'm alone now my husband and two sons
might be in and out during the
day thank
you four five
six okay complet from calling the RO we
have 14 members pres Mr
chair thank you Mr
clerk our first bill this morning is
House Bill 133
it's a bill creating a cause of action
for censorship by social media websites
primary sponsor of that bill is
representative PL and is representative
PL available to testify this morning I
see that he
is can you hear me we can representative
thank you this bill is simple it it it
creates a vehicle for people to sue
social media for blocking content um and
uh of course not all content if it's
injurious to children or or uh or or
indecent uh there's no such right but
otherwise if it's a point of view that
the social media doesn't like they
they've been uh shutting people down and
that that INF fringes right on the
Second Amendment they've got some
Protections in federal law this won't
conflict with federal law because it's a
the state carel in that federal law and
if depending on your political Viewpoint
you might want some things to be shut
down that you don't agree with but the
worm turns and uh we we need to protect
our first amendment rights if I said
second I meant First Amendment rights
for free speech and that's that's the
gist of it I had a late Amendment which
changes the amount that could be suited
up to 75,000 rather than minimum of
75,000 but that's that's the G
it hey are there questions for
representative
PL maybe you could you could just
explain to me what was the impetus for
this is there is there a particular
problem in New Hampshire that you're
aware of that this is directed at um
it's happening across the country it's
happened to my son who's happens to be
an antivaxer in California he's been
shut down several times after developing
followings of 30,000 Plus on Twitter
it's happening in New Hampshire I I
don't have a specific example but yes
it's happening
everywhere
and
is and I guess I guess that's a um just
a followup to that question you you
indicated Andy Andy vaxer uh your son
being an Andy vaxer and a and I'm Pres
ass uming that the social media site has
indicated that his talking about any
vacc
vaccination is prohibited on their site
period yes it shut them down several
times this is one example because it's a
personal example that I'm aware of but
uh it's no problem finding people to
come forward and say there's a concern
here in New Hampshire it's a a PO it's U
it's uh something if they have ties with
the pharmaceutical industry they're
going to shut them down because it's a
bread and butter to them it may be
political Point points of view they
don't particularly care for and we've SE
seen examples of
that are there other questions yes
representative
Burch thank you Mr chairman and thank
you represented for taking my question
um I'm generally not a conservative in
my political Outlook though there are
some aspects that I believe in uh but I
have a question about the
idea that the uh the state of New
Hampshire according to this bill should
be telling private
companies um what they uh uh how they do
their business in terms of what they
post allow to be posted and what they
don't allow to be posted so are you
comfortable with saying to private
companies uh what their speech uh what
speech they allow what speech they don't
uh there's a point in time when a
private company gets so big that it that
it's it it it becomes a common carrier
and and uh should should be open to all
uh if if it's a small entity so big a
deal but when they get it to Big to be
as big as Facebook and Twitter they have
control over uh uh over uh messages uh
and and that that does become a
concern thank
you are there other questions for
representative
FL see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you appreciate the time
not not a
problem and we do have other people who
have signed up to uh testify here
today there was Elizabeth Ellis is
Elizabeth
Ellis
available don't see Elizabeth Ellis on
the list of
attendees and Sher
wac
and I don't see Sher wac on the list of
attendees and Christine
wheel yes I see there is a Christine
with her hand
UPS hi there thank you so much for your
time um so I am in support of House Bill
133 my name is Christine wheelie I am
have uh one heart Ministries I'm in
Minnesota but I also am part of the
special for of Liberty and um I wanted
to just address really quickly the um
point that y all made about um how this
affects people in New Hampshire so my
Ministry is is Nationwide and we have
connections with people in New Hampshire
and I personally have been censored um
uh so I can I can give an example but I
think the main thing is that um the
major social media websites they've
reached a critical mass and they have
done it basically through fraud false
advertising and deceptive trade
practices and because Facebook Twitter
and all of those media sites are so
large now people like me and other
people constituents in your in your uh
State you know when we're censored for
instance well my example was um you know
I posted something in regards to my time
of ministry in Nevada that was censored
and was told it was sexually explicit
when that was absolutely not not at all
anything nothing not one thing in there
was that it was a video of the new of
the Nevada state government um signing
the six electoral votes or whatever for
for for Trump but it was not even like
it was it was an answer to my prayer
specifically of my time in Nevada that
was censored and said it was sexually
sexually explicit so that is happening
that's just one example and um so we you
know as as an a citizen we and the
people in New Hampshire those that I
know even on Facebook who see those
posts and things it's taken away our our
rights and it's taken away um you know
regardless of political party or
religious views um social media should
not be
censoring um its users in the way that
they are and we all know that that is
happening and so I personally um I
support this bill and and running this
legislation across because I hear of all
the the stories whether it's a Democrat
Republican none of that really matters
it's really about just them taking
control over um
you know they have their own interest in
it in mind and so this will give a right
to those citizens who have been defamed
who have been censored to actually you
know uh stand up for their themselves
and and with the um and be able to sue
uh with that
$75,000 which in some cases it
has Christine I think you got uh muted
for for some
reason I think I think my phone muted or
I was M yeah it did briefly there okay
so
anyhow and it seems to have happened
again yeah sorry keeps me out here I
hope that's not the social
media oh I've been having some issues
already just let me tell you that so
just doing this it's everything's crazy
I was censored yesterday I I was
censored yesterday personally with my
prayers going forth in a messenger
voicemail I I do voice messaging because
I I don't always have time to type and I
have people in other states who have
cancer and who um I've prayed for and I
could only you know do the voice
recording and they did not get any of
that and they had surgery yesterday so
that is my person example to bring it
down to a personal level this isn't just
me this is that was someone I was
praying for in Texas who I have relation
so yeah anyhow thank you so much I just
yeah I'm just gonna end it with that I
mean we all know I I this bill just
speaks for itself so okay are there any
questions from Miss
wegley if not thank you for your
testimony today thank
you and are there other people who in
attendance today who would like to
testify I see that there is a cam wette
with a hand up so if Cam wette would
like to
testify good morning thank you for your
time today my name is Cam olette from
New London I work with forces of Liberty
please consider being a co-author to the
stop social media sensorship act HB 133
and vote in favor of this bill I see so
much censorship with my fellow citizens
sharing truth that is challenged by big
dollar corporations such as
pharmaceutical companies government run
programs and other wealthy influences
our first amendment rights are not for
sale there must be a free exchange of
ideas and freedom to make them known
private companies are operating under
the guise of public free exchange of
ideas and now have grown so big they now
choose the narrative that people are
allowed to see literal hate speech and
child porn is allowed and although
reported is considered not against
Community standards but people are are
literally dying and suffering for life
because of lack of access to informed
consent for medical interventions our
country is dying because of lack of
performance of civil duty this is not
taught in our educational institutions
adults are concerned over the
destruction of freedom in America to
pursue life liberty and happiness our
god-given right as written in America's
founding documents people are wanting
information on how to be involved in
their local government process and
connect with local people who want to do
the same and it is being censored by big
Tech because that somehow goes against
Community standards please support
freedom and vote in favor of HB 133
thank
you are there there any questions for
Miss
wette I I
um so the the the bill itself as I
understand it um deals specifically uh
it it prohibits uh social media
company
from uh censoring political or religious
speech and do do you have specific
examples of that in New Hampshire where
this would
[Music]
apply uh yes when um posting information
on uh local political Gatherings or um
trying to gather fellow citizens or
sharing information um regarding medical
interventions um Facebook will remove
posts um they will hide um like if if we
post a picture with a quote from a
doctor Facebook will hide it um saying
that the information goes against
Community standards or is harmful
content um when we should be the
according to our constitutional rights
our god-given rights we have the right
to pursue the information that we deem
necessary for the health and well-being
so that we can pursue life Liberty and
happiness thank you other any other
questions from Miss
wette zingan thank you for your
testimony to me thank
you and uh we have Christopher seier
Esquire
yes sir thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee I'm gonna talk
very fast please welcome to answer I can
answer any questions you have want to
make Five Points first I want to give
you well Four Points I want to give you
a quick background number one 29 other
states are carrying this bill both
Democrats and Republicans are the prime
sponsor of this bill um it was written
out of a lot of this has been litigated
a lot in Federal District Court it is
one of the hottest Topics in the country
it's a b partisan issue my background
very quickly I went to V undergrad V law
school as a Judge Advocate General and
worked briefly as assistant United
States Attorney here's Four Points
number one well the the question
presented is what's the best solution to
the pro ongoing problem of social media
censorship which is completely out of
control is it an executive order by the
president is it Senator Josh Holly's
attempts to repeal section 230 of the
communications decency act or is it
represented the pl's bill House Bill 133
and the answer is it's representative
pl's bill because it falls Within What's
called the state law exemption under
Section 230 it's subsection e paragraph
three and so what what does that mean in
plain English what is section 230 well
section 230 is in a is a statute created
by the federal Congress in the 1990s
that get creates uh immunity for
internet intermediaries and the way I
have to understand it is through an
example so the best way to understand it
is if someone post a defamatory comment
on YouTube the defame party can sue the
person that defamed them uh but if they
name YouTube in the lawsuit then YouTube
could invoke a section 230 immunity
defense and be dismissed from the case
so that's a good use of section 230 it's
actually good law but it's being abused
in New Hampshire out substantially it's
being abused in this way when when
people in this state get censored for
their religious or political worldviews
and they they try to bring any kind of
cause of action against tech tech
companies are then invoking section 230
immunity defense and saying your honor
we're merely
editorializing and so well our our I is
that section 230 the communication the
communications decency Act was created
to protect decent speech it was never
created to promote deceptive trade
practices so that's point one the best
solution is representative pl's Bill
point two is what does this bill say the
so the stop Social House Bill 133 says
this it says going forward in the state
of New Hampshire any retailer well it
says going forward if a social media
website censors a user for religious or
political speech and that social media
website was always marketing itself from
its Inception as being free fair and
open to the public and if they have more
than 75 million subscribers if that kind
of social media website censors then the
injured party can seek up to 75,000 in
statutory damages attorney fees actual
damages and other forms of relief 75,000
is a magic number because it gives a
litigant the option to litigate in
federal district court or in State Court
under what's called diversity
jurisdiction the fact that it says
attorneys can the injured party can seek
attorneys Fe fees means that local
lawyers would have incentive to
represent uh your constituents when
they're being censored and shut down by
social media websites because of a thing
called the American rule which says you
got to have a statute that allows there
to be recovery in order for a litigant
to seek that um so at point three this
is very important contract law is a
state law issue now when you sign up for
social media websites you're entering
into an adhesion contract which means
the cours won't really take it very
seriously however those social media
websites are reaching into New Hampshire
and inducing your constituents to sign
up to use their services and when those
you know contract law is a state law
issue and when your constituent signs up
for Facebook Twitter or YouTube and they
you know after they've been promised
that it's free fair and open to all
ideas only to turn around and be
censored okay that's not that's what
attorney general b called it the
greatest bait and switch of all time but
that that kind of commercial practice
amounts to breach a contract bad faith
unfair deal ing unjust enrichment
fraudulent inducement this is a
deceptive trade practice bill it's a
progressive Bill really because it gets
existing law to catch up to modern day
technology point three the underlying
constitutional federal legal
prescription for this bill is the first
amendment free exercise clause free
exercise clause and the um free speech
Clause of the First Amendment now New
Hampshire's Constitution says the same
thing because the free the first
amendment applies to the government it
restrains the government from
encroaching on free speech so it's
really restraint but it can be used as
as a trampoline as a catalyst when um in
a situation like this where the uh tech
companies have set out purposely to
induce people to sign up to their
websites only to turn around and sensor
them they've induced people to sign up
because they marketed themselves as
being open all ideas ideas and they've
reached critical mass as a result of
that they have set out and purposely
created a digital Public Square for them
to turn around and censor your
constituents now is per say deceptive
trade practice deceptive trade practice
is not a protected form of free speech
the opponents of this bill generally
show I make one more point I'll stop
yeah if you would just kind of wrap up
yes sir sorry this is this very complex
First Amendment law so I'm just trying
to be helpful to the committee on that
on that topic last Point there's some
exemption is exceptions they're common
sense if the if if the issues are
pornographic in nature if it's caused to
immediate acts of violence if it's false
impersonation uh respectfully Mr
chairman there are three proposed
amendments we would suggest we've had
hearings on this bill in seven different
states this past week and there's a
couple of amend a couple of small
amendments we've been picking up in
different states number one we would
recommend under subsection 8 sub
paragraph a we recommend that uh a
subparagraph in addition that to be
added under eight that if the con if the
speech constitutes copyright or
trademark infringement that the social
media website could censor that if the
content is access ly violent that would
be Point number nine under that same
section then they should be able to
censor and then finally if the content
constitutes harassing spam of a
commercial but not of a political or
religious nature uh they can be censored
and I'll stop with that thank you for
giving me that extra time if there's any
questions I'd be glad to try to answer
those and and I'll stop there thank you
so much members thank you are there yes
representative wber do you have a
question yes Mr cier did you submit all
this and writing to us
uh yes sir I did there's uh there's
talking points there's proposed
legislative findings that we've used in
other states um that are a little bit
more robust it's all in writing uh and
yes sir yes
sir okay any any other questions for
attorney
seier say none thank you for your
testimony today yes sir thank you the
next person is and we do now have
Elizabeth Ellis with
us good morning chairman Gordon um can
you hear me we can oh wonderful um thank
you uh my name is Elizabeth Ellis and
I'm vice president of state government
Affairs of the Motion Picture
Association I very much appreciate the
opportunity to appear before you today
to share mpaa's members concerns
regarding House Bill
133 Me MPAA member companies are the
leading producers and Distributors of
Motion Pictures and other audiovisual
works for all media platform platforms
including Motion Picture theaters
digital video home entertainment cable
satellite and broadcast television as
well as on the internet our members are
no doubt familiar names to you Walt
Disney Studios Paramount Pictures
Netflix Universal Studios Warner
Brothers and Sony Pictures House Bill
143 one excuse me 1144 would create a
new private right of action allowing a
user and I'm sorry the bill was
obviously 133 a private right of action
allowing a user who speech has been
deleted to sue for $75,000 per deletion
plus actual damages punitive damages
plus quote other forms of Equitable
relief if their online comment is
removed MPA member companies and their
Affiliates are host to platforms which
allow viewers to post comments and
reviews and the definition of social
media website in this bill is so broad
that it would Encompass many companies
such as MPA member companies that allow
users to share comments or product
reviews online MPA member company Disney
for example owns ESPN which allows
sports fans to comment on online stories
and it's sometimes necessary
unfortunately for Disney to remove
certain inappropriate material shared by
a user in their comment or review in
order to ensure a positive online
experience for the rest of their viewers
but by doing so this bill could then
make the Walt Disney Company liable for
$75,000 every time they have to do this
plus Equitable damages punitive damages
and other forms of relief
while we don't believe our member
companies are the intended targets of
this legislation the definition as I
said is so broad that they unfortunately
would fall squarely within the scope of
this bill and the new liability that the
bill would create not just for our
member companies but for many larger
businesses that allow user generated
content we also believe the bill is
unconstitutional as an invasion of the
editorial process that's barred by the
First Amendment the First Amendment bars
the state from interfering with
editorial decisions including by
websites and internet platforms about
what to print or not to print and we
also believe House Bill 133 would be
barred by section 230 of the
communication decency act section 230 as
you of course know is the federal law
that bars States from either imposing
criminal liability or providing a civil
cause of action against websites
platforms social media sites and isps
related to user generated content for
these reasons we respectfully request
the committee defeat House Bill 133 I
would just like to add that while it is
true that this bill is showing up in in
state houses around the country it has
been for several years now and no
legislature has ever enacted it um I
very much appreciate the opportunity to
appear before you today and I'm happy to
answer any
questions are there any questions from
melis representative wper H yes thank
you Mr chairman thank you my question
did you give us a WR testimony on this I
will forward it um right now thank
you thank
you seeing no other questions again
thank you for your testimony today thank
you and is there anyone else who would
like to testify this morning on House
Bill
133 yes I have a Cameron
schy
good morning chairman Gordon I
appreciate your time this morning on
house B
133 I'm the director of government
relations at the Heartland Institute um
I will not um uh belabor my points I
will submit my uh testimony to the
committee afterwards but a few points as
I'm listening in I did want to get to to
uh help with um your decision- making on
on this bill um particularly
representative Burch asked the question
um how does House Bill 133 square with
free market principles and how does the
state um
justify involving itself in what seems
to be A Private Matter between a
corporation and a
user um big Tech operates in a
government corrupt Market it exploits
the government corrupted Market to its
advantage and opposes free market
reforms and therefore is not entitled to
object to state government political
Free Speech protections uh that
allegedly violate those free markets
free market objections to New Hampshire
uh stepping up to protect Free Speech
fails to recognize that the tech cartel
neither formed nor operates under free
market conditions big Tech would not and
could not exist without government
favortism and
protection eliminating those favoritism
and protections is the ideal
solution however uh in the absence of
such an ideal solution existing or
appearing imminent Americans vital Free
Speech rights must Trump corrupted
Market uh commercial
interests to that point a little bit
further um industry opponents of this
idea of pro of providing redress for
censorship andess
um enjoy a government sanction Market
where the dominant players are largely
immune to competition by which our
economy is underpinned uh that section
230 of the 1996 telecommunications
decency act exists is prima fascia
evidence of a corrupted Market uh for
big Tech the status quo is lucrative and
rewards their own Pious views while the
users from which they profit are subject
to their
whims um I I'll leave it at that submit
my written testimony to the committee
but I am happy to answer any
questions thank you very much um Mr schy
are there any questions from the
committee
members seeing none than thank you
again and is there anyone else who uh is
in attendance who would like to
[Music]
testify seeing no one we'll close the
hearing this morning on House Bill
133 next bill this morning is House Bill
453 that is a
billing journalist for mandatory
disclosure of sources by subpoena
primary sponsor of that bill is
representative Reed and I'll call upon
representative Reed to provide uh
testimony or introduce the bill if
representative Reed is
available
and I don't
n is that you representative it is
indeed can you hear me we can oh
excellent I was afraid I wasn't being
seen for a second um thank you Mr chair
and thank you honorable members of the
committee I will be pretty brief I think
uh for the record my name is Ellen Reed
I represent Rockingham 17 which is New
Market in newfields I also teach
American government in community college
and uh every semester I teach my
students quite a few things but I teach
them obviously about the First Amendment
and the various parts of the First
Amendment one being the freedom of the
press I teach them about the importance
of media whether that influence be
negative or positive on our democracy
how much of an influence the media can
have and um most importantly I think or
one of the most important things I teach
them is the fragility of democracy um
most democracies have not stood for very
long historically we are the oldest
still functioning democracy and there
are a few factors that lead to the
stability of democracy I won't be labor
all of those but I will emphasize that a
well-informed public is absolutely
crucial to a well-functioning democracy
without a well-informed public by by
definition people cannot then have the
information to make informed decisions
on choosing their
representatives so the media is and
we've gone through a lot of recent years
of of issues with the media and um
Integrity in the media but the media is
absolutely inextricably linked to the
functioning of our democracy in fact
it's called Uh the fourth estate or
fourth Branch because of that it is the
way in which citizens have an ability to
have a check on their government and
because of that because of the
importance of the media I'm introducing
this here reporter Shield
law um I do have to teach my students
every year that despite the fact that we
have a freedom of the press in some
places in the country and it has
happened um dozens and dozens of times
in recent years uh judges can jail
reporters for not disclosing their
sources now it would be and it is
whenever happens a tragic blow to
democracy to weaken the media so that
they cannot adequately Source material
if their sources are unwilling to talk
to them because they aren afraid that
they would be exposed um then simply put
the journalists can't really fully
operate on the most sensitive and most
important issues of our day and we've
seen issues like this when it comes to
um you know uh well I won't I go won't
there's obviously Edward Snowden and
juliia ass Sange and all of these issues
that have happened but I just want to
highlight the importance of a robust uh
um media that can Source information
particularly when it's damning to the
government and particularly when those
exposed those people who are sourcing
that information if they were exposed
might come to harm so uh the we are only
one of 10 states that does not have a
shield law in place in our current law
uh Most states have some level of
protection uh if we passed this bill as
it stands right now which is extremely
broadly written and I'll get to that in
just one second we would join 17 states
that have absolute protection for
journalists States like Alabama Kentucky
uh Nebraska
Montana however I'm not necessarily
advocating that we pass the bill as it
is written right now um there are a
number of uh factors that can influence
this and so I anticipate questions as
it's written right now would be things
like well what defines a journalist or
what if there's a particular type of
Court scenario where you have to get a
certain certain piece of information
endangering public Liberty or Public
Safety or whatever something like that
and the reason I submitted this is
because I didn't really my goal here is
to have some protection for journalists
my goal wasn't to dive into the weed on
and try to advocate for particular
definitions so Mo many states and my
intention is to send this information to
uh your committee right after this
hearing with the hope that one or more
committee members will reach out to me
and be willing to work with me on an
amendment that suits the needs of this
particular committee but for example
many states like Florida and Georgia put
a um definition on the word journalist
that that journalist has to be paid I do
want to have the argument of well if
it's a paid journalist are we then
disenfranchising say people who blog or
doing their own independent thing are we
giving more preference to mainstream
media these are questions that I would
like the the Judiciary Committee to
answer for themselves they're not
positions that I particularly want to
advocate for or against I just want
would love this committee to take this
issue seriously and engage in whatever
language you all deem suitable to
protect
reporters um and then the the final
thing is why New Hampshire New Hampshire
as far as I know and there have been
dozens and dozens of situations of
reporters being jailed even for months
um for not disclosing sources as far as
I know New Hampshire has no such problem
but when it comes to uh constitutional
rights and this is certainly falls under
that in terms of freedom of the press I
am a strong believer that we put those
rights out there affirmatively
and not in a reactionary way dealing
with the problem after it's already
happened um and certainly the framers of
our constitution felt the same that's
why they took the steps to ensure the
Liberties that they did it's also why we
have the Ninth Amendment the ninth
amendment of course for those of you who
know uh states that all of the other
amendments in the Bill of Rights
notwithstanding there are no there are
other rights that we have as a people
that they did not enumerate and they
went to the pred a whole amendment to
say and those rights are also protected
we just haven't enumerated them so I am
uh a proponent of being assertive when
it comes to uh protecting uh uh our
individual freedoms that are guaranteed
in our Constitution and uh with that I'm
guess I'm happy to take any questions I
just sincerely hope that this committee
I know that you all are a busy committee
but I hope that you all are willing to
give it this particular issue about
journalism um the time and effort that
it I think it deserves and thank
you are there questions for
representative
Reed I I guess I think you started to
address do you consider a person who is
a blogger a
journalist um again this is there there
would be Arguments for and against and
my entire point is to strengthen
protection of of of the the journalism
community and not try to Define who is
and isn't a journalist I think this
committee is probably well equipped to
make those decisions on their own there
would be arguments that some bloggers
have access um or have an independent
voice that mainstream Media or other
sources that would be able to pay
professionally a journalist might not
have so there's a good argument to
protect bloggers but then where do you
draw the line anybody can call
themselves a blogger so it those types
of questions I would love if the this
committee even in a subcommittee or or
work study work group um if you all
could decide what you all think is the
most appropriate so long as we are
recognizing that the journalism
Community does in fact need
protection representative bur did you
have a
[Music]
question yes it's and thank you
representative for taking my question
not sure quite how to phrase it because
because um when I read your bill uh it
seemed so broad uh and didn't take into
account uh the balancing that courts do
when they issue uh delicates aenis like
this uh and I gather from your testimony
you're saying you have a good idea here
and your opinion and you'd like the
Judiciary Committee to uh come up with a
uh answer is that basically where what
you're saying well I don't expect the
committee to start from Whole cloth I am
about to uh send you the email I didn't
want to get Lo getting lost before the
hearing but send you an email now that
you know it's coming with specific
language examples in other states that I
um various other states both uh
conservative and and liberal leaning
States uh that kind of narrowed us down
what I'm asking is that the committee
take it seriously enough to decide from
those options which of those options a
combination of those options is most
appropriate in New
Hampshire followup no no no further
questions if if I could make a
suggestion representative
Reed we we you indicated we're a busy
committee and we are and we're running
out of time in terms of reporting out
our bills and we already have a very
busy agenda agenda and I
certainly in terms
of amending your bill to make it
workable I don't think that's something
that could happen in the time frame that
we have our only alternative would be to
hold on to the bill and do some work
later if the committee elected to do
that I guess the so my suggestion to you
is if you think that there are changes
that ought to be made I think you should
probably be the one forming that
Amendment instead of asking the
committee to do that for
you I I understand completely and my my
goal was not to kind of off-put work
onto the committee I just understood
that perhaps I didn't want to assert
whatever you know relatively arbitrary
definitions that I might come up with
over what the committee would want so
I'm happy to come up with an amendment
and uh that kind of reflects the average
for the country the various States again
I as I said 40 states have some sort of
protection um and submit that to you all
with the understanding that I'm saying
right now it's not that I'm married to
these particular ideas but if if doing
that work ahead of time before you've
had that discussion helps you all that's
fine also if the committee decides that
because of time you cannot have those
discussions before crossover then um I
would ask that you retain it and and uh
look into it seriously when you have
more time
and yes representative Simpson do you
have a
question I do thank you Mr chair thank
you representative Reed for taking my
question some of the things that you're
talking about make me think that the um
press Association here in New Hampshire
might be a good resource for you in
these if you are going to think about an
amendment on your own um and I wondered
if you have a sense of whether they're
open to that kind of conversation or um
resourcing or support indeed it was
actually and this is a conversation in
the Hall of the lob some three years ago
um with a member of the press
Association that sparked my putting this
in I have since I mean this is going to
be a little bit maybe too honest I have
desperately looked for this man's
business card and I cannot remember who
he is and I cannot seem to hunt him down
so I don't know how to get a hold of him
but I have uh welcomed a number of
Journalism associations to participate
with me um obviously if they are doing
other things and prioritizing other
things then um that can't be helped but
I do welcome the New Hampshire
journalism Association as well as other
organizations to work with me on
that do you have a follow-up question
representative I do if if you if you may
um I think my question then is that I'm
just wondering if you know if it's
pressing for them as a group or if they
and not that you presume to know what
they what they think but I I guess I've
had my own curiosity about how the
federal law operates here and um
wondering if you if you know how
important it is for them to have this in
New Hampshire that's ke yes the federal
there is no federal Shield law despite
different journalism associations very
repeatedly and very vifer usly
advocating for it um it is something
that just has not happened yet on the
federal level despite happening on the
state level in most of the country I
don't think the New Hampshire
Association finds it a particularly
pressing issue in New Hampshire for the
you know the reasons I already said we
don't apparently have a a particular
problem with journalists being jailed
however as I said in my testimony when
it comes to uh these types of individual
freedoms that are guaranteed in the
Constitution I believe in taking an
affirmative stance and not waiting for
whatever powers that may be come into
power and then abuse that Authority I
believe in having those Democratic
safeguards in place to begin with as did
the framers of the US
Constitution thank you that's really
helpful for me thanks any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you very much Mr
chair we have one other person who has
their hand up that's
lenr uh that that would be me I just
lowered my hand but I do believe there
is a representative from a press
Association here who wanting to testify
and there's a uh men
Fiddler yes that's hear me yes we can um
good morning and thank you for the
opportunity to speak today on House Bill
453 um my name is me fidler and I am a
legal
hello hi sorry it looks like I got muted
there um did you hear anything I said
just your very beginning in your
introduction it was all um so just to
back up a little bit I'm here um for the
reporters committee for freedom of the
press the reporters committee was
founded by Leading journalists and media
lawyers in 1970 when the nation's news
media faced an unprecedented wave of
government subpoenas forcing reporters
to name confidential sour
today its attorneys provide proon legal
representation amikas support and other
legal resources to protect First
Amendment freedoms and the News
Gathering rights of journalists across
the
country the reporters committee supports
shield laws as very important
protections for
reporters um as representative Reed
mentioned states of long recognize the
importance of protecting reporters
through shield laws today 39 States and
the District of Colombia do have shield
laws in
place shield laws are important because
reporters necessarily rely on
confidential Communications with sources
to report the news for public
benefit compelling journalists to
divulge confidential or even
non-confidential Communications with
sources chills news Gathering and
deprives the public of important
information in particular some of the
most important stories uh have relied on
confidential sources from the classic
example of Watergate to reporting on the
war on terror to revealing unlawful
surveillance
practices and at the local level to give
a recent example a lot of reporting on
covid-19 which was crucial to getting
accurate information to the public so
they could adequately protect themselves
would not have been possible without
Healthcare entities being able to speak
confidentially to trusted members of the
media furthermore compelling journalists
to disclose this information to assist
law enforcement increases the likelihood
that members of the public will perceive
the press as an extension of law
enforcement rather than as a neutral
Observer last a single legal demand
affects not just the work of the
targeted journalist but all other
journalists whose sources will hesitate
and hold back information on significant
matters of public concern if courts take
up the invitation to scrutinize a
reporter's news Gathering
process in conclusion the reporters
committee supports the passage of this
Bill thank you
are there questions for Miss
Fiddler seeing none oh representative
Simpson sorry thank you this is not an
area of expertise for me so my apolog
apologies but I have a question if 39
States is a lot of states and so I was
just wondering if in those States these
shield laws arose out of particular
cases or if
um or out of out of um
I don't know fear is the right word but
for not being able to do the job
properly um that's a good question
representative Simpson I believe it
probably was a mixture um I'm not
familiar sort of with the the Genesis of
the laws in every one of these states um
but certainly a mixture of principle and
uh real danger and I should underscore
it's not just a fear of journalists
being jailed that motivates these laws
um the mere fact of a subpoena can have
a pretty significant chilling effect
itself
representa
bur uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
Miss vidler or attorney fidler for
taking my question uh I I want to be
sure about your position are you saying
that you Andor your organization
supports this bill as it is written in
its present form or are you saying you
support the concept of the bill and uh
depending on how it might be
amended uh thank you for that question
we do support the bill in its current
form as representative Reed mentioned
there are I believe 17 States who have
similarly broad protections and it's
been found to be fairly workable so um
in terms of the definition of journalist
we think strong subpoena protections
should apply to anyone who's engaged in
legitimate news Gathering so from our
perspective this bill doesn't need to be
amended there are ways that you could
amend it and we would still support it
as well
thank
you I guess if I could just follow up on
that you know being being an attorney
I'm quite used to the idea of having
attorney client
privilege but there are certain
exceptions to that so it's not an
absolute privilege
and this appears to be an it's a
followup to represented burch's question
really it this seems to be an absolute
privilege uh
um is it and I and I guess you've
perhaps already answered the question is
that is that the the
typical typical manner uh that these are
adopted in other states that it would be
an absolute privilege not a not some
type of balancing or not concerned with
criminal activity Etc uh yes
representative Gordon so the the best
shield laws are um do provide this kind
of absolute privilege and we've largely
seen them to be workable
um so I would recommend uh moving in the
direction of an absolute privilege if
you are able to do
that thank you there any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today and is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on
453 if the if you do wish you need to
raise your
hand
and I don't see anyone else who wishes
to testify so we'll close the hearing on
House Bill
4 leave us with about five minutes
before our next hearing i' note that on
House Bill 453 there were eight people
who signed up to in support of the bill
and three people who signed up in
opposition
for your information on House Bill
133 there were 52 people who signed up
in support and 11 in
opposition
yeah
the next bill that we'll be hearing is
is House Bill 584 which I'll call to
order at exactly 10 o'clock but just um
in anticipation of that just to let you
know that there were 13 people who
signed up in opposition to House Bill
584 and there were zero people who
pre-registered in
support
for
well call
relative to guilt by association and
defamation by media
Outlets the primary sponsor of this bill
is representative
baldasaro and his representative
baldasaro available to testify this
morning I do not see him on my list of
attendees
wace is representative
wace available to
testify is there someone who would like
to introduce the bill
I'm representative Horgan okay well
first of all I just wanted to say that
I'm I'm I'm here I'm home in my office
alone and um I'm not necessarily
authorizing anything the bill says but I
here to introduce HB 584 relative guilt
and Association defamation by media
outlets and um it appears that some you
to require uh media Outlets here in New
Hampshire to publish uh publish
extensive updates on criminal cases and
other controversies that they report on
so that's a that's my understanding of
the bill as I read it so I probably so I
I guess I'll do the traditional thing
and take any questions although I would
probably be unable to answer any of them
um so that's
a and and I said I'm also then as I said
I've also like formally acknowledged
that I'm here home alone in my office
etc etc so thank you well welcome and
thank you for your introduction thank
you there are people who did sign up to
testify uh
including uh Brendan McCay MC
and Quade would you like to
testify yes hello good morning good
morning I hope everyone can hear me we
can um yes my name is uh Brendan McQuade
I'm president and publisher of the New
Hampshire union leader uh I am here on
behalf of the New Hampshire press
Association and we uh strongly opposed
this bill um as I think uh anyone who
actually reads the text of this bill
would see this bill is patently
unconstitutional um the idea that you
can force media companies to print
something uh has long been struck down
in the history of this country and is
anathema to both the First Amendment to
the Constitution of the United States as
well as to the New Hampshire
Constitution um I would strongly suggest
that members take a look at the
provenance of this bill this seems to be
an activist bill that has been
introduced both in Mississippi and in
Rhode Island and very quickly either
voted down or actually withdrawn in both
those places um because of its uh very
nature there seems to be a guy who is uh
quite against the media and has um tried
to introduce this to punish the media
for their uh transgressions against him
anyway um the bill uh being uh
unconstitutional uh sort of stands by
itself um I will talk briefly about what
I think uh people who see a bill like
this would uh tend
to understand as the as the reasoning
behind it um and it's a it's a very real
concern for people that are accused of
crimes that they have a um uh an
accusation against them comes a matter
of public record the accusation goes out
there the arrest record goes out there
and for many people that is the end of
it because a lot of these things um end
in you know pre-trial they don't
actually uh follow through so we as the
Press don't get any follow-up
information on these things unless we're
notified about it and the union leader
as well as all professional press uh you
know members have a process that we go
through through anytime we're contacted
by someone who is affected by this type
of thing we actually will uh take a look
at what they submit to us and we will
decide whether there's an update or a
correction that should happen um
sometimes there's a full-blown story
that follows up to uh actually explain
the outcome of a case
um we're happy to listen to any
suggestions that folks may have about
that process about how we could do it
better um I would strongly urge you to
not consider this bill as a solution to
that problem just read the bill um it is
completely outrageous the way that it uh
demands within 10 days that a a
publication uh change what it has
previously published uh the $110,000
fines that it attempts to impose um as
well as further damages beyond that uh
the the chilling effect especially on
smaller Outlets would be substantial
um let's see uh sorry just trying to go
through my notes make sure that I've
covered everything
um the the main concern here and I think
it's important for the members to
realize this we had a similar bill that
came up uh last year um the problem here
is not the local media the local media
is who's going to be affected by this
bill
but the problem is Google and that's the
that's the thing that everyone is
frustrated by and that's what we hear
most often is people call us and they
say I Googled my name and your story
about me came
up unfortunately that's a Google problem
more than it's an us problem I mean
we've kept archives four years we didn't
go back into the microfilm and white out
the stuff that um you know changed
Google makes it so easy to delve back
into these records that uh it really
does become a problem for people that um
their Digital Life when you look at
Google often becomes their most
prominent thing which sometimes is an
arrest that does not look very favorable
upon them um so that's why we do
everything we can to update to put the
disposition of a case if we have
appropriate records for that so that
people have a full understanding of the
picture but again this is not the way to
do it if you look at it it actually says
that U we can no longer run the mug shot
if if we have uh a mug shot of the
person if there's a you know further
disposition of the case well sometimes
the mug shot is the story we had a case
in Manchester where the guy's mug shot
actually showed that he was roughed up
by some folks during the course of an
arrest and that became the story if we
could no longer run that mug shot it
would just be ridiculous we wouldn't be
able to tell that story anymore so um I
urge the members to consider this bill
inexpedient to legislate as it is and um
I hope you will uh listen to uh the
further folks I think there are probably
some legal experts who can give you some
more of the background on the history
and the legality of bills such as this
but um I'm happy to answer any questions
as it relates to the Press
are there questions from M MC yes
representative
Simpson hi thank you I think this is a
simple question I just don't know the
answer to um when you rerun a followup
if there is one to rerun do you rerun
the mug shot with it or do you um have
another picture that you rerun with the
saying that maybe uh a person was found
not guilty or something like this do you
rerun the mug shot or or seek to find a
different picture that's not um so it
depends on the story usually we will
update the story as it exists so story
is a snapshot in time right newspapers
are often considered the first draft of
history and that's where we like to keep
it so we will actually update that same
story so if there was a mug shot with
that story it will often stay with that
original story with a a header or an
update um on the story to let people
know that there actually has been a
disposition to the case
but if if there's a if there's a um uh
if there's a a trial that we're
following that we're actually you know
allowed to be in the courtroom yeah
we'll usually run a picture from that
because that's an update on the
story Senator
Chase thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question Brendan
um it when something is done incorrectly
a story isn't written correctly or more
information comes forward and I know
that a lot of media will just put in a
little blurb saying in last week's
column so and so was said and this was
not correct do you when that's done is
it is it
attached I'll say online or in some type
of a media situation to the um the
original article so that that also comes
up immediately when somebody searches
would that help with this
so online yes that th those Corrections
tend to get made to the online story um
that's the way that that works in print
you actually um you know it's it's just
a practical matter you don't want to
repeat the mistake in a correction so
you actually print what the factual
information should have been you don't
repeat the same mistake so you would
cause further confusion to the reader
thank you very
much any other questions for Mr
mcade see thank you for your testimony
today thank you all very
much Gregory
Sullivan sorry about that I had to
unmute my myself good
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee uh thank you for allowing me
to testify my name is Gregory Sullivan
I'm an attorney a represent Union Leader
Corporation and the New England First
Amendment
Coalition um as Mr McQuay just
testified this bill is blatantly
unconstitutional it's black letter law
in the United States and I'll talk
quickly about the case of Miami heral
versus uh
orello um and I'm going to just give
three quotes from that case which was
the Supreme Court of the United States
in
1974 it says dictating what a newspaper
must print is no different from
dictating what it must not
print press responsibility cannot be
mandated by
legislation and thirdly there can be no
intrusion into the function of
editors I mean that's the law and this
bill is just lies directly in the face
of that law clearly I'd point out it's
not just criminal cases that this this
bill addresses either it's civil cases
so under this bill if someone sues for a
million dollars and they get a dollar or
they get
999,000 whatever it is the newspaper is
mandated to run a follow-up story and
not only is it unconstitutional it's
completely impracticable for the press
to be able to track every single civil
criminal administrative case that that
happens in the state um in in the law we
have a phrase void for vagueness there
are so many provisions of this bill that
would be subject to anyone's differing
interpretation that it it clearly is
void for
vagueness um so I'm not gonna take up
too much of your time but I will point
out that part one article 22 of the New
Hampshire
Constitution uh is even stronger in its
protection of the Free Press than the
first amendment is uh it says that the
Free Press and and Free Speech are in uh
essential to the security of freedom in
the state and therefore must be
inviolably preserved well this bill uh
does not in any way uh inv viably
preserve the freedom of the press it
does just the opposite and I'll be glad
to answer any questions I I'll State as
Mr McQuade did now I've been
representing the union leader for over
40 years something I'm hesitant to
admit uh but there was no Google uh back
in the day and from then to now Union
Leader has done everything it possibly
can and many other Professional
Publications of the same way to rectify
errors um because as as the banner head
of the union leader says there's nothing
so powerful as truth and that is indeed
what the union leader seeks to publish
day in and day out and now even on
unionleader.com
and the New England First Amendment
Coalition I'll mention is is a group of
uh attorneys editors journalists and
concerned citizens in the city six New
England states and its uh executive
committee has instructed me to speak as
vehemently as I can in opposition to
this bill and ask you to deem it
inexpedient to
legislate be glad to answer any
questions you may have thank you
attorney Sullivan representative D
Lorenzo thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Sullivan for taking my question so in
your opinion would you say that this
bill has no redeeming Merit
you know I I think the motivation behind
the bill is understandable um I've
represented clients who felt that they
were unfairly treated by the Press but
what I've done is is is called the
editor of publisher of the newspaper not
the local state
representative um so I think the
motivation as Brenda McQuade said is is
understandable there are problems that
occur but it's up to the press to uh
take care of those problems as best they
can and the press that I'm familiar with
do it every day thank you may I follow
up you may
um so have you Mr uh Sullivan have you
heard of any other states that are
trying to
um project this
legislation only the two that Mr mcade
mentioned which were immediately knocked
down
there there's similar legal concepts for
example the right to reply for a
political candidate um and those efforts
to mandate the Press giving equal time
to various candidates have been stricken
for the same reasons uh we've discussed
and were dealt with in the Miami Herald
case back in
1974 thank you very much welcome any
other questions for attorney Sullivan
n thank you for your testimony today
thank you very much those are the only
people who pre-registered to testify is
there anyone else in attendance today
who would like to testify on House Bill
584 I see no one with a hand raised so I
will close the hearing on House Bill
584 and we're not scheduled to
have misjudged the amount of time
I to have another hearing until 11
o'clock so I think the best thing to do
is to recess until 11 o'clock and we do
have a bill at that time which will have
a number of
speakers and sponsored by one of our
committee
mates okay we'll see you at 11 oh M
excuse me representative
Smith thank you very much um Mr chair
first of all I think you own no one an
apology for trying to guess in advance
the amount of time you need for each
bill this is not an exact science and
you've done very well um my other point
is um I gased when I saw the Tuesday
schedule and the number of bills that we
have to
exec and
um worry about the proverbial throwing
out of the baby with the bath water if
we don't really have time to focus on
the bills where we can make a
significant contribution so my question
is are there any
bills now that you
feel comfortable
enough
with to perhaps have us um exec and I'm
not second guessing you I'm not I don't
even know if there are any I'm just
raising it as a possibility since we
have 45
minutes just
one uh unfortunately there there are
first of all it's unfortunate that we
have to meet on Fridays at all but it's
just our schedule has brought us to a
point where we need to do that with a
number of bills that we have but there
are people who just can't make it
because they have conflicts on Friday
and that's why I put the exec session on
Tuesday when I think people ordinarily
would expect to be here so um but I've
told people since they can't be here I'm
not going to exec bills so I really
don't feel I can do that thank you very
much but what what I what I am hoping
and what I would uh what I was
anticipating telling everybody is what I
I hope people will do is go through the
bills in anticipation of new day with
the idea that they have an understanding
of what they uh would like to exec and I
certainly am going to do that in advance
and try to provide as much leadership as
I can because there are some bills
perhaps even the last bill that we heard
that might be obvious in terms of an
outcome and and try to get those
addressed and get them done quickly and
go through as many bills as we can but
I'm with you I don't want to rush
through bills and and produce a bad
product because that that serves
nobody's interest I think so we'll do as
much as we can on
Tuesday thank you Mr chair and then uh
we'll do if if we have to carry stuff
over to the following week till the 10th
then we'll do that uh and but we need to
get everything done on the 10th you know
if if we can't get it done on the 10th
we could always recess and do it on the
11th but I but everything has to be out
on the 11th and I'd rather get it done
on the 10th so we can get the reports
done and get
everything then is
syvia uh thank you Mr chair um I have a
question uh regarding procedures um at
one o'clock we have HB 440 for which I
have a an amendment y essentially
replacing the bill as far as uh
if we were in committee
um
uh ordinarily if I were a co-sponsor on
a bill I would not be uh able to ask
questions am I what is what what would
be my situation as the sponsor of the
amendment which essentially is becoming
the
bill it's becoming the bill I would I
would think that you
would uh that you would testify but then
not participate in the question and
answer
portion okay great appreciate
it representative Corgan um well well
first of all I apologize for being late
at straford county executive committee
actually an issue am I muted and an
issue that came up there we were G to
have the full delegation meet on town
meeting day which is the 10th so that uh
we be meeting in the morning or the
afternoon on the 10th but that's
scheduling factor to consider um so just
thought to bring up those two points as
for 440 I guess technically the
amendment doesn't become the bill until
we accept it in executive session which
may or may not happen but I thank
represent Sylvia for expressing his
concern so and so that's what that's
what I had to say so
um I think town meeting I I think town
meeting day is the ninth if I'm not
Tuesday the 9th okay maybe oh I know
maybe that may have a okay you're right
of course I'm sorry I think that arose
because one of the members of our one of
our towns is having rescheduled their
deliberative session for the 10th or
anyway my apologies so that's
uh not a problem we we ordinarily would
meet on the nth but because this time
day we can't meet as a commit that's why
we scheduled the meeting oh perfect yes
that makes
sense
sovia did you have another
question no I was trying to figure out
how to put my hand down in the
no I am now home in Belmont so I'm gonna
go back to my regular
device thank
you okay and representative
bur you're muted Paul yeah just to note
that in West Milan we do our voting for
town meeting on the 10th
you do your voting for town meeting on
the 10th
yeah if I can just ask how how how does
that
happen uh that's we normally do it on
that Wednesday and this is going to be
by drivethru so I'm not even sure how
it's going to
[Music]
work but we'll figure something
out
sorry
anything
else and we'll recess and reconvene at
11 o'clock thank you Mr chair thank you
everybody
[Music]
right
that
[Music]
for
this
e
for
morning again everyone we call us
meeting to the house Judiciary of the
house Judiciary Committee back to
order our next item bu of business today
is a hearing on House Bill
I'd note that uh prior to the hearing 59
people signed up in support of the bill
and zero people signed up in opposition
to the bill and two people signed up as
neutral to the bill there were there are
eight people who pre-registered to
testify
today House Bill 540 is relative to
supported decisionmaking as an
alternative to guardianship the primary
sponsor of that bill is our own
representative Chase and representative
Chase I'll call upon you to introduce
your
legislation thank you very much Mr
chairman and members of the Judiciary
Committee my name is Wendy Chase I am in
State Rep for straford County district
18 and I'm also a member of this
respected committee HB 540 would create
an alternative to guardianship for
adults with disabilities and their
families who wish to establish a way of
providing support without taking away
self-determination under the current law
there are very few options when a family
is looking for a way to provide support
to their loved ones with a disability
this issue often comes up when a young
person is about to turn 18 and the
family wants to continue supportive role
in the areas like Education Health Care
and public funded services but right now
there are no recognized meaningful
alternatives to guardianship which
involves the removal of decision-making
powers from the person and it gives it
to the guardian appointed by the court
the power of attorney can be used for
financial and Health Care decisions but
these Alternatives typically involved
the full takeover of the decision for
someone and they are often only
available when someone becomes
completely unable to make a decision for
themselves 540 would
create a legal recognized alternative so
that people in a range of circumstances
can be provided the support they need
without the court removing their freedom
of choice when this is unnecessary to
meet their needs people with
disabilities often simply need what we
all utilize from time to time we need
support at various stages of our life in
various subject areas most of you on the
committee may look for help in
understanding important complex
information when making important
financial decisions for example or you
might seek advice from trusted friends
and relatives when facing challenges or
M M yeah momentous excuse me decisions
involving your health this bill
recognize the reality and it makes that
kind of support formally available for
adults with
disabilities the bill will not disturb
the availability of guardianship for the
people who need for sometimes to have
people make their own decisions for them
if this bill was to become law the
standard for creating a guardianship
would still remain the same as it is
today the bill merely creates an
alternative for those common
circumstances where support is needed
but no removal of self-determination is
and just a little notice to why I am
supporting this spill so wholeheartedly
is because I did become the legal
guardian for my love beloved daughter
Aaron at the age of 27 until she passed
away at the age of 34 in
2018 Aaron became physically disabled at
age three when she developed a rare
Childhood Cancer that left her with many
unknown and known medical issues the
side effects from the treatment also
left her reasoning and her emotional
levels a bit IM mature which does happen
and in certain situations it caused her
to think with her huge big heart and not
always with her head I saw guardianship
due to her many trips to the emergency
room where I was no longer able to have
a voice I couldn't help make decisions
in her care and sometimes I was not even
able to stay in the room during a
consult usually I was met with that same
social worker who told me over and over
that I needed to get full guardianship
to legally continue Contin to be part of
her care so I
did and it wasn't what either of us had
expected and it tended to drive a stake
between our loving
relationship she felt she lost so much
of her independence and her selfworth
and I just wanted to be her mom I didn't
want to have to control her life if
supported decision making had been an
option as an alternative to the
guardianship I can't even begin to tell
you what a difference that would have
made in my my daughter's life my life
and most of all our relationship I want
to thank you once again for the
opportunity to bring HB 540 before you
today I hope you will listen well read
the testimonies from New Hampshire
residents where this legislation could
make a very positive impact on their
lives or the life of someone they dearly
love and next Mike skibby the
director uh from the DRC will be
testifying after me and he can respond
to to your questions about technical
aspects of this current law and again I
thank you very much for this
opportunity thank you representative
Chase are there questions for
representative
Chase seeing none thank you very much oh
I'm so sorry I'm sorry um chair Gordon I
did also send an a amendment in un
approved Amendment for this which I
think you all should have received
and Mike can also talk about that if
needed
thanks that would be
helpful if you don't have it I can
resend
it okay we do have some other co-spon
ERS who uh wish to testify and I'll call
upon them first and then we'll get to Mr
Skiby and uh representative Weber has
requested to
testify thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee uh my name is
Lucy Weber I represent chesher 1 which
is the Connecticut River towns of
Hinsdale Chesterfield West merland and
my own town of Walpole
and one of my past lives I was um an
attorney starting in Wills trusts and
probate and then with a focus on what
was then in the emerging um field of
elder law now I'm just an elder um
but I cannot tell you how much as an
attorney I would have valued having this
kind of a um process available uh to to
for just the sorts of people that
representative Chase um described and
let me offer my sympathies on the loss
of her beloved daughter um it allowing
people their autonomy is a crucial point
of all of our lives and and allowing
people to make their own decisions as
best they can uh a lot of what's in the
bill is simply a matter of contract but
and why not just have contracts well
um a lot of what's in the bill helps
with things like getting access to
information that um holders of that
information like um the IRS and other
organizations don't want to release
because they don't want to invade
people's privacy but a decision helper
might need access to them um and I also
like the fact that there is a
slight reference also
to the ability to refer to DHHS which of
course is already in statute to Adult
Protective Services if if somebody
encounters a um a dis a supporter that
is not making decisions in the best
interests of the um of the ward um the
addition of the duty the fiduciary
duties that are incorporated into this
uh bill and the fiduciary standard are
really necessary and I think it's a
great concept I thoroughly support it
and I look forward to hearing Mr skibby
talk about it more but with that I will
end my
testimony thank you very much are there
any questions for represa
Weber seeing none thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank you
and I think Senator Whitley would like
to testify as
well thank you Mr chair and good morning
members of the committee for the record
my name is Becky Whitley and I'm honored
to serve New Hampshire Senate District
15 which includes the communities of
conquered Penacook hener hopkington and
Warner I am proud to co-sponsor and
testify in support of HB 540 and today
I'd like to share my personal experience
with supported decision-making as an
alternative to guardianship my
sister-in-law who lives in a different
state experiences a developmental
disability with significant cognitive
impairing
impairments she is also kind incredibly
perceptive loves animals plants and
people and is an incredible part of our
family she is 39 years old and lives an
incredibly full life also before covid
she lived on her own and filled her days
with work friends and play practice she
has lived the a very full life for many
years without the assistance of a
guardian but instead through the strong
support of friends Family Support
professionals and through formal and
informal supported
decision-making for Generations people
with intellectual and developmental
disabilities have been overprotected
overcontrolled isolated segregated and
excluded from our communities and we're
often forced to live in places removed
from the lives and experiences that
people with disabilities take people
without disabilities take for granted
this kind of segregation and
overprotection has led to a constrained
life with a loss of power autonomy and
other rights for so many people with
disabilities we have long classified and
categorized individuals who experience a
disability rather than supporting them
as important and cont contributing
members of our society guardianship has
long been the primary vehicle to
so-called protect people experiencing a
disability from making bad or wrong
decisions about their lives and
resources however awarding guardianship
over a person person can often result in
significant removal of basic rights that
should not be taken lightly it can often
result in people experiencing a
disability being treated as if they were
less than and incapable of managing
their own lives including the most basic
of life's choices people under full
guardianship have no right to make their
own decisions about their health care
their finances their relationships and
other day-to-day decisions people under
guardianship are often less likely to
live in their own homes or Apartments
less likely to have jobs in the
community and less likely to have
friends this supported decision-making
model gives individuals experiencing a
disability like my sister-in-law a voice
and helps them make their own decisions
we all rely on others to help make
decisions in our lives and people with
disabilities may need more or just
different type of help no one should be
kept from making decisions about their
life because of the type of support they
need thank you so much for allowing me
to testify and I'm happy to take any
questions are there any questions for
the
senator see none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you okay we have a number of other
people who have signed up to speak
today um and but I think uh
representative chase you asked that you
could have U Mr scabby speak so we'll
have him speak
next
good morning um my name is Michael
skibby I'm the policy director at the
disability Right Center of New Hampshire
I'm here to testify in support of House
Bill 540 um I want to thank
representative Chase for her uh Prime
sponsorship of this bill and for sharing
her story it's been a powerful
experience um for me to um hear about
her um experience with her daughter um
and I've had a similar um experience
talking to several of the co-sponsors
including Senator Whitley um it's one of
the great things about my job to uh to
talk to Representatives who frequently
have the kinds of experiences that you
know my office is really focused on on a
day-to-day basis so thank you to you
representative Chase and to the other
co-sponsors including Representatives
Burch Langley and you Mr chairman um
this bill is a result of a collaborative
effort over the LA better part of the
last year um with input from lawyers who
work in the field National experts and a
drafting work Group which included
members of organizations such as New
Hampshire legal assistance AEL New
Hampshire New Hampshire family voices
and area agency and granted State
Independent Living supported
decision-making has received significant
attention nationally in recent years in
the last five years 10 states have
adopted statutes like House Bill 540 uh
would adopt um in addition National
organizations such as the American Bar
Association the national guardianship
Association have uh have made policy
statements in support of the
establishment of supported
decision-making as an alternative in
appropriate cases to
guardianship there have also been
initiatives that have been funded by the
Federal Department of Health and Human
Services to um explore and develop
supported decision- making in the
various States I think to appreciate the
value of this bill it's important to
understand the basics of guardianship
it's the complete removal of
decision-making and Choice by the court
and the granting of that um authority to
an appointed Guardian now the court May
tailor and limit its order of
guardianship but only in this sense of
the subject areas that it covers that is
if a guardianship is imposed with regard
to Financial decision- making for
example or housing decisions in that
area are no longer controlled to any
degree by the person with the disability
they are controlled completely by the
guardian commonly guardianship is
granted in Broad areas including
providing for things as basic as food
and clothing and shelter but also health
care and safety and management of
property and financial affairs when it
is broadly imposed it's very similar to
the complete responsibility and
Authority that a parent has has over a
minor child now this is an important
legal option to have available if
someone is truly incapable of making
decisions on their own behalf to any
degree this bill would not remove it as
an option for those who are truly in
need of that level of intervention what
this bill would do however is create a
legally recognized alternative to
guardianship that recognizes that many
people with or without disabilities need
support and advice when making important
decisions but often only need need
support and advice not removal of their
freedom to make their own
choices I suspect that like me all of
you turn to trusted professionals or
friends and family for advice about
important decisions it may be to help
with understanding certain unfamiliar
information or helping to recognize and
weigh the pros and cons of certain
Alternatives that is essentially what is
meant by supportive decision making and
it works for people with disabilities in
much the same way as anyone
else
people with disabilities who might
otherwise be considered candidates for
guardianship are frequently able to
manage the choices and decisions in
their life so long as they have the
support and advice that they need now
support May mean something like
modifying the language used about a
certain subject or helping to gather
information that would be helpful or
having a supporter present during
meetings with doctors or other service
providers this is a good example I think
in a lot of our lives in my own case as
my mother was at the end of her life my
siblings and I would attend doctor's
appointments with her not because she
was unable to continue to make her own
decisions but because it was helpful to
have one of us there to help frame the
conversation in a way that allowed her
to understand and to assess the pros and
cons of her choices and with our support
the choices continued to be her choices
not someone else's made on her
behalf they were not always the choices
that we would have had we would have
wanted for her but they were her choices
and that was an important component of
her quality of life at the end of her
life now House Bill 540 essentially
recognizes the reality that many of us
can retain our F freedom of choice so
long as we have the support we need it
probably goes without saying that if
anyone is able to re is able to retain
their freedom of choice they should be
permitted to do so what may not be so
obvious is that the maintenance of
self-determination has significant
benefits for an adult with disabilities
beyond that as the parent of an adult
using supported decision-making recently
told me decision- making is a learned
skill and as it is learned other things
come along with it people who maintain
their self-determination have been shown
to be more independent healthier both
physically and psychologically and
better able to recognize and resist
abuse and exploitation they also tend to
be more integrated in their communities
that is they're more likely to live and
work with others who are also or not
also people with
disabilities now the bill is summarized
in some detail in my written testimony
but let me just briefly explain that the
first few sections make changes to
existing law to help facilitate
implementation of supported
decision-making and of the new statute
that is created by the bill sections two
and three of the of the bill make minor
changes to the guardianship statute to
identify the availability of supported
decision-making as one of the things
that a court can consider in determining
whether guardianship is the only way to
support and protect protect a person
with disability and also as a basis for
concluding that a particular
guardianship is no longer
needed section four deals with special
education law and it deals with the
specific issue of transition of a
special education student this is an
area of current responsibility of
special education staff to help prepare
a child with a disability for adult life
after schooling is completed sometimes
this includes discussions of whether
guardianship should be pursued by a
family Upon a Child turning 18 now
families often pursue guardianship
because they do not know of alternative
ways to remain involved in their child's
life in early adult into early adulthood
and once guardianship is in place it is
very uncommon for it to be undone what
the bill would do would be D would
direct that special Educators include
information about the supported
decision-making alternative if they have
discussions with a family about pursuing
guardianship it does not require that
such a discussion occur Ur but it does
require that if a guardianship
discussion occurs that it include the
alternative of supported decision making
that section of the bill further directs
that the Department of Education prepare
information to be used in such
discussions so that local school
districts are not required to prepare
their own
materials the remainder of the bill sets
up the new chapter establishing
supportive decision- making as a formal
alternative to guardianship um I won't
go through it uh line by line but I do
just want to point
out some of the I think key components
of the of the new statute um on page
four line 23 it lays out the necessary
components of an of a of a adequate
supported decision-making agreement it
requires that there be at least one
supporter a description of the subject
matter a description of any subject
matter that is excluded from the uh
Arrangement um how it has to be written
and dated and witnessed uh so forth um
on page six starting at line 16 it
describes the fiduciary relationship
that supporters need to uh have to their
principal and how their Authority is
limited to what is given to them in the
agreement on page seven starting at page
starting at line 10 it talks about who
may not be supporters including
employers or employees of the principal
people who are paid to provide services
to the principal or people who've been
convicted of certain offenses or against
whom orders or protection have
issued on line 34 of that of that same
page page seven um it describes the the
obligation um to make a report of abuse
if a persons who are aware of abuse or
exploitation by a supporter um uh uh I'm
sorry if they if a person becomes aware
of such abuse or exploitation by a
supporter um I think that
um um in conclusion I just wanted to
point out that um New Hampshire uses
guardianship actually more than the
average State um I looked at some data
from about four years ago from a survey
of adults with intellectual and
developmental disabilities who receive
state agency services in the various
States now among that group The
guardianship rate nationally was 56% 56%
of those people surveyed around the
country had Guardians in New Hampshire
it was
76% um three quarters um 20% higher rate
than the national rate so that could
mean a lot of things but I think it's a
probably pretty strong indication that
we may have people under guardianship in
this state that could be successful
using other models of support and so it
makes sense for us to make sure that
people have a range of alternatives AES
and House Bill 540 would be a strong
step in that direction without
diminishing the availability of
guardianship for people who know need
that level of structure and sub
substitute a decision
making thank you for your attention I'd
be happy to answer any questions thank
you representative
Paige thank you thank you Mr chairman um
and thank you for taking my question
attorney skibby um I have a question I
read that the New Hampshire school
special ed
administrators Association had some um
questions I believe they supported the
bill I don't want to mate what they
wrote in their letter but was my
recollection and and it looks like
there's an amendment to that I think
provided by um representative Chase um
does that
address their concerns because in their
their memo they had noted they would be
talking with with you so I wanted to see
if if that if you if you feel like
that's that amendment's comp has been a
a compromise and then the second part if
I may is whether if you could if if if I
if you could just sort of
describe what the the in the sharing of
that information would look like so that
it would be a
meaningful um um sharing at the IEP
table I think thank you um
representative Paige um and I probably
should have um spent a few moments on on
uh the amendment that uh representative
Chase is going to be bringing forward um
to take the last part first I think
probably helpful to think about how this
responsibility put on special Educators
Educators would be um would be fulfilled
and and what we have in mind is the
development of a fairly simple piece of
written information like a pamphlet that
would be developed by the Department of
Education ation that would be available
to an IEP team that is the group of
special Educators that work with a
family um to hand over to the family as
they begin this discussion of possible
guardianship if they choose to have that
discussion so that that that their
responsibility would be fulfilled by
simply passing along the information
that had been developed by the
Department of Education and I think the
Department of Education is directed to
basically consult with
organizations like my own and many of
the other disability rights
organizations in the state um to develop
a relatively straightforward explanation
of the supported decision-making
alternative now the the amendment
itself um makes some uh some I won't
call them stylistic decisions uh uh
changes but um some modifications to the
language of um um section four of the
bill that came as a result of a
discussion I had with the uh specialed
administrators
Association um it would make clear that
the obligation would only arise if there
is an actual discussion of guardianship
with a family not if it's simply being
considered which is the current bill
language um it also would
um um
make some
changes with regard that just sort of
clarifying how let how um releases of
information would have to be executed by
the principal would not be executed by a
supporter there's some additional um
concern that they raised I believe in
their letter if I recall it correctly
about what they've referred to as a hold
harmless provision um I think I need to
give further consideration to that and
perhaps have some further discussions
with them about whether
that would make sense um I think the
liability concerns that they may have um
I don't think I share those concerns but
I'm I think I'm willing to and I think
that that representative Chase is
willing to give that some further
consideration thank you representative
Sylvia thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question Mr sky and
before I get to the question uh my
question i' like to apologize the flow
of information coming through email
these days is swamping US particularly
me I guess and uh I have gotten emails
and paid attention to them but haven't
gotten back to you so as to my question
um this the language in this bill is is
good I like a lot of it there is one
concern that I see for these folks and
particularly the support people uh
there's been disc discussion a lot of
discussion over the last few years about
uh statutes for V vulnerable
adults and it would seem that the
support persons would be possibly in an
awkward position uh should such a uh
statute be enacted do you feel that
lacking that um that proposed
legislation are are these folks
uh going to be protected enough by the
current statutes that they won't be
subject to
abuse um thank you for the question
representative Sylvia
um so if I if I'm understanding your
question correctly it's it's it's
getting at whether the use of a
supported decision-making
agreement um would make an otherwise
vulnerable person um more vulnerable
than they would be in the case of
guardianship is that is that the gist of
it yes uh it seems like there's a lot of
responsibility for the sport person and
right uh is there a danger to them is
there a reason for them to be afraid
that signing up to be a sport person
would be a problem for them well I you
know it's certainly something that I
think anyone should um should consider
carefully before entering um into to but
but I I think that um you know it is a
completely voluntary Arrangement and no
one is compelled to be a supporter um
who does not wish to be I think it's
probably good to recognize that these
kinds of Arrangements exist today
although they may not be formally um
recognized so for example just as you
heard Senator Whitley describe and there
were other co-sponsors who described
similar situations to me where they have
a family member that they they basically
act as a supporter just as the this
statute would comp uh would contemplate
um but it's done in an unformal informal
and unrecognized way um and so they've
they've stepped forward to provide
assistance and I they don't incur any
liability by doing so and I don't think
any liability is incurred by this
statute itself and the statute
recognizes that a supporter may decide
to terminate their involvement in a
supported decision-making agreement
what I do think is helpful here is that
the the the formalizing of this uh as an
option it
basically
um it draws the attention of all parties
to the agreement the principal the
person with the disability and the
potential supporter to what it is that
they're signing up for the agreement
basically identifies to the supporter
that this is the obligation that you're
undertaking and it requires the
supporter to ack knowledge that they
understand that um and I think that
that's good for both parties to the
agreement so that there's no
misunderstanding and potential you know
the potential of of something dropping
between the cracks as you might have in
today's you know
circumstances I also think when we are
thinking about
vulnerability the research shows that
people who enter into these agreements
or otherwise maintain their
self-determination by avoiding Guardian
ship are actually less likely to be
exploited and less likely to be
vulnerable um because as I was
discussing before when people have that
self-determination they tend to be more
aware of what's going on around them and
more ability to assert themselves to
avoid abuse and exploitation so I think
it certainly makes the people with
disabilities probably more resilient not
less resilient and I think the
formalizing of the agreement probably
makes it more likely that somebody who
agrees to be a supporter will go in with
their eyes wide open
rather than under today's regime thank
you any other questions for Mr for
attorney give yes representative
Smith thank you very much Mr Speaker um
uh I first want to begin by sympathizing
with what representative Sylvia noted
that we are um
drowning in emails in text messages in
material that we do or do not print out
and it's very hard to make sure that
we're not missing any information that
would help us make an informed decision
um we received some uh written testimony
from um an attorney in um in New
Hampshire whose name is Sheila
Zachary and I don't know if you have had
an opport I know you know her I don't
know if you've had an an opportunity to
discuss anything with about this bill
with her but her testimony is really uh
I think very interesting um she talks
about what she sees as rather over Brad
definitions and um for example quotes
most people with disabilities have the
ability to make decisions for themselves
when they are provided the necessary
information and support to do
so um uh Miss Zachary's interpretation
of this is um less than positive um she
uses a a very interest there is a
question there is a question uh Mr chair
um I won't explain more about what she
says but as you read the language
particularly in the statement of
findings do you have any sense
that certainly not by um
intention uh but by result that the
language in the findings in some ways
insults or
diminishes um the awareness of the
ability of people with disabilities to
make informed
decisions um thank you you for the
question representative Smith um I don't
know attorney Zachary um um but um I I
know of her and I know that she is a a
lawyer who's done work in this field um
for some time
um I guess um all I can say is that as
the person who drafted that language um
I don't think it um communicates what um
attorney Zachary takes it to communicate
but I wouldn't dispute that she honestly
um received it that way um and if others
receive it that way and the committee
wishes to modify those findings I think
that is absolutely fine with me and if
you'd like me to participate in a
process to um to um adjust the language
I would be happy to do that they are not
definitions so they you know changing
that language will not disturb the
actual um law after this bill is
hopefully um uh brought to final passage
so I I would have no problem if it is
the will of the committee to make
adjustments to those findings so they um
are not offensive to anyone could I
follow up you may thank you very much Mr
chairman so um is it safe to say Mr
skibby that in your judgment if we um
elim minated or severely
modified uh the statement of findings
and focused instead on the actual
language of the um of the bill for what
you propos to do that we would not be
weakening the
um the import of the
bill that is what I that is what I I
mean to say that I I think that you can
you can adjust the statement of findings
um uh significantly or even eliminate
them without changing um uh the the uh
the substantive law that would be
adopted by The Bill thank you very much
Mr Skiby thank you Mr chair thank
you there any other questions for
attorney
skibby I did I did have just one
question quickly and that is what
level with most estate planning type
documents there has to be at least
some um level of competence in signing
the document what level of competence
would a person have to have in order to
enter into this
agreement well I think
um let me just find the section Mr
chairman
um
I think that what I would refer to
is
[Music]
um is on page five line four which is
basically a continuation of the previous
section which talks about the components
of a valid agreement and the standard
there is that each party to the
agreement has signed the agreement
voluntarily and with an understanding of
the nature and effect of the agreement
so there's I think that's the closest
that the bill has to what you're getting
at if if the person does not understand
what it is that they're entering into
then they the agreement that they enter
into would not be valid um I think that
there was not an attempt to try to
Define some threshold of capacity in the
same way that other areas of law do
because I think the point is that there
is a sort of dynamic relationship
between the capacity um and you know
collection of strengths and weaknesses
that the person with disability may have
and the type of support the intensity of
that support the subject matter of the
support um and the skills of the
supporters that if if those mesh
together I think there can be a range of
capacity that would work for the person
with a
disability so long as they understand
what they're getting
into so and any we were talking about
special education earlier but in um as I
read the document it applies only to
adults is that correct that's correct
because the the the um you know the a
minor does not have the sort of
authority that um would be taken away by
a guardianship they they basically are
under guardianship until age 18 by
virtue of their parents right and I
guess the the last question I have is um
so I'm a I'm a doctor and somebody shows
up and they have this type of an
agreement um so and my concern is to
what extent can I rely on the agreement
I
guess I really all I
can all I can really do is a do I can't
really rely on the the support person
based upon this because ultimately it's
the decision of the person who entered
into the agreement the principal in the
agreement and I can't really rely on
what the supporter might tell me to do
like a power of
attorney well I think that's right but I
think it's important to emphasize that I
mean this this makes no change in terms
of the sort of legal Authority I mean if
someone is not under guardianship then
it's the patient the adult patient who
is in the driver's seat when it comes to
healthcare decisions or you know there's
analogies in in many other subject areas
as well and I think what the what this
law would do would be to recognize that
there are some people who need support
of one type or another to be able to
make informed decisions and to
communicate those decisions I it may be
an inadequate analogy but I think it may
be helpful is um just as someone who
uses a sign language interpreter sitting
in the doctor's office the doctor may
not be able to discern directly what the
what the wishes of the princi of the
patient are but through the use of an
interpreter they are able to discern and
their responsibility to conform to the
wishes of their patient um remains even
though there may be a different way of
communicating uh with the patient thank
you any other questions seeing none
thank you for your testimony today thank
you
uh there are other people um who wish to
testify and the Sheila Zachary I don't
know if I'm pronouncing that
correctly um I am here I just unmuted my
microphone can everyone hear me we can
okay thanks um I did did provide written
testimony um as um as representative
Smith stated and I'll I'll go through um
that testimony so that you get if you
didn't have the opportunity to to read
what I sent over to the um committee you
you can get the get the understanding I
think of of uh the comments that
representative Smith said and then I
don't want to take too much time but um
I I do want to just give you my
perspective as a member of the public
and as an attorney who has um sat many
times with families to discuss
guardianship versus alternatives to
guardianship as well as sitting in in
special education meetings kind of what
really happens um from a from my own
from my own experience um good morning
and thank you for accepting my comments
regarding HB 540 a bill regarding
supported
decisionmaking my interest in this
legislation is manifold I was born with
a significant visual disability in 1958
so I'm in my 60s I've a lot of
experience with this and I've had
lifelong experience with the ways in
which people with disabilities are
treated differently from individuals
without disabilities sometimes
inadvertently or with beneficient
attention I have been an attorney for
over three decades which includes over a
decade as a former staff attorney at the
disabilities rights Center in Conquer
New Hampshire and currently I have a
private law practice that specialized in
a wide range of legal issues affecting
people with disabilities and the senior
population including discrimination
Estate Planning in the event of future
disability and
guardianship I am also the parent of an
adult with a developmental disability
who is not under guardianship who lives
independently and works in conquered and
he's also a client he on the
developmental disabilities uh
waiver however what most informs my
understanding of the issues facing
people with disabilities is my firsthand
experience that being said I was put off
by language in this proposed
legislation the purpose of this
legislation is to provide an alternative
to
guardianship I support that
purpose however right at the outset the
statement of findings makes over broad
inaccurate and untrue statements about
persons with disabilities generally the
group it purports to help for example
under the statement of findings
paragraph two reads quote most people
with disabilities have the ability to
make decisions for themselves when they
are provided the necessary information
and support to to do
so and in my written testimony I I
italicized the phrase when they are
provided the necessary information and
support to do so this perpetuates a
negative and untrue view of people with
disabilities as being less competent and
less capable generally than people
without disabilities because of that
qualifier that they can only make
decisions when they are provided by
someone else the necessary information
and
support the flip side of this are
those backhanded compliments such as you
do very well or I don't think of you as
disabled that have been directed to me
by professionals and colleagues and I
don't think that I am alone as being the
subject
of the people who have said such things
to me are well-meaning but the
underlying assumption is of course that
I shouldn't be doing that well solely
because I have a
disability so getting back to the
statement of findings I suggest that you
substitute the word women for the phrase
people with disabilities and see how you
would like it if the statement of
findings read most women have the
ability to make decisions for themselves
when they are provided the necessary
information and support to do so I think
a lot of women and men would find the
Assumption insulting because it assumes
that men have the ability to make
decisions for themselves without the
support of someone else but most women
could make those decisions with that
additional
support um look at statement of findings
paragraph three quote trusted friends
family members and professionals can
help people with
disabilities understand the choices they
have and how to live their life
lives again the Assumption underneath
the statement is that first trusted
friends family members and professionals
would not be people with disabilities
and second that we who have disabilities
need these people to help understand the
choices we have and how to live our
lives again sub for the term people with
disabilities and see how you like this
wording trusted friends family members
and profess profs can help women
understand the choices they have and how
to live their lives that sounds pretty
paternalistic um I I also suggest in
paragraph four um if you were to
substitute the word woman or women for
the phrase adults with disabilities so
that the sentence read women have a
range of strengths exper and experiences
and guardianship is unnecessarily
restrictive in many of these
circumstances um it kind of hearkens
back to perhaps a 19th Century view of
women is needing to be under the
protection of men but obviously they
don't need to be um so I think that if
you compare if you kind of Simply
substitute some language i' suggest that
you might find other places in the
proposed Bill where the term person with
a disability is not inappro is not
appropriately limited to the class of
people that this legislation
addresses um I.E those who might be
subject to a
guardianship um in some the state of
findings that is proposed is overly
Broad and perhaps
inadvertently perpetuates a negative
view of all persons with disabilities
most of whom have never been nor will be
the subject of a
guardianship so I have a suggestion by
amending the legislation to eliminate
paragraphs 1-4 in the statement of
findings reum renumbering paragraphs 5
through through eight as 1 through 4 and
adding in paragraphs 6 and 8 the words
who might otherwise be subject to
guardianship after the phrase person
with a disability you will eliminate
this over Brad and and inaccurate
depiction of people with disabilities as
a group and better serve the Bill's
purpose so that concludes my my um my
written testimony
and I just wanted to say that with
regard generally to um to supported
decision making of um I'm I've been
familiar with with this for a while I
tell I tell my clients that it's not
here it has not yet been um um passed in
New Hampshire I was asked by the um
family of law section of the American
Bar Association to contribute a piece um
to their um their Journal um a year or
so ago um about guardianship and its
Alternatives and um and I I mentioned
that this is a Hot Topic because the ABA
has um has adopted a provision
supporting supported decisionmaking as
an alternative to guardianship but you
know in my in my in my own practice and
experience um I think the the real issue
is is changing what guardianship is so
Guardian ship and the guardian sees him
or herself as more of a mentor because
as attorney Skiby stated the reality
with supported decision-making and I
don't I don't really take a position on
this field one way or the other but the
re but my first reaction when I first
learned of this concept A couple of
years ago was was was well that's what
people are doing already you know if
you've got a family member and you have
a disability and you need certain
assistance such as my son who is now in
his 30s um we're doing doing that
already and um and I we don't and he has
powers of attorney which is another
alternative um so if I need to do
something in consult with him as his
agent I can do that he has not lost any
P any any rights of his own um in the
educational context I don't know if it
was mentioned but typically what schools
will accept for a child who is 18 at
which time in special education the um
the um rights that the parent has
automatically transferred to the child
is an educational power of attorney and
I draft these all the time for my
clients as I believe other attorneys may
do as well and basically what that is
it's a general P it's a it's it's your
general power of attorney um with with
which includes educational Powers so
again the child is is able who make any
decisions that he or she may want to
make with um in terms of education but
it also gives the child the option of
saying well you know I don't want to go
to that meeting my parent can go you
know um and believe me there's a lot of
kids who don't want to go to their I
meetings there's a lot of parents who
don't want to go to the IP meetings
either um and so so um so again you know
and thinking about alternatives to
guardianship for for people perhaps it's
not this is not the uh this is this is
not going to be the time for it but I
really think that the the issue is more
you know making is changing the nature
of guardianship making the guardian if
court appointed someone who becomes more
of a mentor and is understood that way
as opposed to somebody who basically can
overrule the decision of the person who
has the disability um so I think that's
all I have to say um I'm certainly happy
if anyone has any questions about my
perspective or disagrees or agrees with
my perspective or has any questions
generally about my own experience um as
um as a a parent of a CH of of an adult
who has a disability um or the
guardianship I've I've represented many
people both as the proposed Ward as well
as the guardian and guardianship
proceedings in New Hampshire over the
last 30 years and um' be happy if
there's anything that I can say that
might help you make your decisions on
this Bill thank
you are there any questions
representative okay I see no questions
so thank you very much for your
testimony today and I want to thank the
committee and the chairman for giving me
this time to speak thank you we have a
Teresa Olen Martin who wishes to
speak good morning good morning I wasn't
sure it was going to work this is my
first experience doing this remote thing
like this um my name is Tesa Olson
Martin and I live in Webster New
Hampshire I want to be clear that I'm
speaking as a private citizen but I also
work at a Statewide organization that
helps families who are trying to find
the services and the supports that they
need to raise their children and young
adults with special Healthcare needs and
disabilities I really appreciate the
opportunity to talk to you about House
Bill 540 I'm here to share information
that I've learned both as a parent and
as a person working with other families
my experience includes being the
guardian of my 40-year-old son for the
past 22 years and involvement in
guardianship proceedings for my father I
also provided input to the um writing of
house spill 540 filing for guardianship
was and is a difficult and emotional
process it's yet another time when I had
to face the reality of what my son
couldn't do it's not something anyone
anyone looks forward to families who ask
me about guardianship frequently ask if
there are other options
they say things like do I have to do
this he's working really hard to become
more independent he's still
learning I tell them that our current
system allows for guardianship or things
like power of attorney or healthc care
proxy that's what we currently have most
people have some familiarity with those
options but they don't really feel like
they meet their needs guardianship is
unfortunately the choice most families
make with a lot of
reluctance as parents we don't want to
stand up in court in front of our child
because it is expected that that young
person be in the court and talk about
all their deficiencies and the labels
that they've received over the years in
order to gain guardianship so that we
can continue to support them and help
them we want to be building up their
self-esteem we want to be telling others
about all the great gains that we've
seen and what we think can be
accomplished with a little more time how
they're going to be able to do great
things rather than doing the negative
talk especially when we continue to see
them gaining skills and making progress
we're not being unrealistic we're still
being
hopeful however we're also being told
that we will have no input once the
young person reaches 18 if we don't have
guardianship schools are unaware of
other options Banks lawyers doctors have
all been taught that as of 18 the
individual makes all their own decisions
unless you have guardianship
families are seeking options that will
help their young person to continue to
gain the skills they need to take care
of themselves without taking away their
individual rights supported
decision-making is a tool to assist the
young person and the family it allows
the young person to maintain their
ability to make their own decisions and
it gives the family knowledge that a
plan is in place to support that family
member if families have provided
information on options at schools and
places where our kids are getting
Services we can make informed decisions
together about the option that is best
suited for our family
circumstances I learned about supported
decision- making about four years ago
and I've talked to families about it as
an option however because it's not
recognized by the New Hampshire um
legislation and the courts they feel
that it might not be acknowledged when
they're working with others um in their
young person's life and it's scary to do
something that's different if you're not
sure it's going to have validity
to the Professionals in their lives how
much push back are you going to get are
you going to have to constantly be
explaining and um and trying to make
your point we're tired it becomes one
more thing to explain and depending on
your relationship with others it can be
difficult to have the acknowledgement
that more than one person may need to be
involved in this decision-
making professionals who may have never
heard of sported decis are the ones
telling that telling you that you have
to file for guardianship it's how you
protect your loved one we do want to
protect our kids we also want them to
gain more and more Independence families
are conflicted and I certainly
understand those concerns I ask that
whatever you decide that you remember
it's a difficult process and families
want to continue to be involved thank
you and I'm happy to take questions
thank you very much for your testimony
today are there any
questions seeing none again thank you
for your testimony today
there are three other people who
pre-registered to testify uh none of
them asked for more than three minutes
and we're getting to sort of the end of
our time today if they could present
their and they're all testifying in
support of the legislation so if they
could uh provide their testimony uh
representative mc mc Beth did you have a
question thank you when I signed up
online I couldn't check that I wanted to
speak but I'll speak at the end I'm not
asking to speak now but I just and I
I'll only take three minutes as well
thank you thank you
okay uh is Jessica gof
available yes can you hear me we can
great um so honorable members of the
House Judiciary Committee thank you for
allowing me the time to read my
testimony uh my name is Jessica gof and
I'm a resident of conquered New
Hampshire I'm a master of Social Work
student at UNH and a policy intern at
the New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities um I want to
speak in strong support for HB 540
members of the disability community and
their families who live in our great
state deserve a less restrictive
alternative to guardianship the practice
of guardianship inherently removes the
given rights of adults with disabilities
to make decisions and engage equally in
the world around us often This legal
transfer of choice-making power from
what we call the ward to the guardian is
done in totality and encompasses
everything from control of money to
making decisions around healthare
education housing and even the ability
to get married for some this means
removing the right to vote and to
testify in court given these severe
limitations to an individual's autonomy
guardianship should be viewed as the
last resort but in order to reduce the
rates of Guardianship and allow for
adults with disabilities to take a
leading role in their lives we need less
restrictive legal options that assist
individuals to make informed decisions
with those who they trust supported
decision-making has been hailed as a
balance alternative as seen in the
momentum throughout the advocacy and
legislation across the country um as was
talked about a number of well respected
organizations have come out in support
including the national guardianship
Association uh the stated purpose of
appointing a guardian under current New
Hampshire law is to quote unquote
protect the well-being of incapacitated
persons who are unable to provide for
their own personal needs due to
functional limitations uh we need to
recognize that well-being is a concept
that should encompass comp more than
just safety we need to think about
quality of life and access to the full
rights of citizenship in both the course
of my graduate education and my previous
work as a direct support professional
with adults with disabilities I've seen
both the detrimental effects of force
control and the amazing benefits in the
capabilities of individuals when they
are given the opportunity to sit at the
head of the table and making decisions
that affect their lives right now
parents of Youth who are transitioning
into adulthood are given a seemingly
impossible choice to take their child's
right to choose away or to allow the
young adult to preserve the legal rights
but eliminate their ability as parents
to support their children in what they
need to be successful this bill would
allow a comprehensive third option which
would enable adults with disabilities to
keep their rights but ensure that they
have access to needed supports with the
guidance and of and assistance of their
supporters I urge you to vote OD to pass
on HB
540 um again I just I believe that this
is a really great bill in the work that
I've done I've seen so many individuals
who are very capable of making choices
who have a guardianship often appointed
by the state who they may not even know
um so they have individuals making
choices for them without their input uh
because guardianship is inherently
taking someone's rights away um that is
the purpose of Guardianship and so
another option would really allow people
to be able to get access to services and
have that codified under law so as
representative Gordon you were talking
about as a doctor under current law an
individual can have this decision
informally um but if they bring it to
you you're not really sure who to listen
to who has the legal rights um but this
would put it into law so that you're
fully aware of exactly in what domains
the supporters are able to get
information um when they're able to be
present in appointments to get that
information how Hippa applies and
everybody is on the same page um so
thank you for allowing me to provide my
testimony thank you representative MC
Beth thank you Mr chair um so I I
apologize for being late this morning
but I actually was in the um Probate
Court actually representative MC Beth
you said you wanted to go last no I
don't I didn't have to I just mean I
don't want to jump but I'll no
I just just hold on and I I'll get the
other and and let you have the last word
okay I thought you had a qu I thought
you were asking a question as Judith
Jones
available well Miss Jones you need to
unmute well the first law of speaking as
an attorney is to unmute can you hear me
now we can thank you so much so
my name is Judith Jones I've practiced
law New Hampshire since
1998 the focus of my practice has been
on assisting older adults and
individuals with disabilities I'm
pleased to have the opportunity to
support House Bill 540 so you've already
heard the testimony in favor of the
house bill and focusing on that it's a
model to support individuals with
disabilities in communicating their own
decisions in their Liv lives and it's
really based on this it's based on the
premise that all individuals have the
right to make decisions that impact
their lives as others have said our
current system is really based on
substituted decision- making and other
making a decision for me what this does
is really shift the framework of our our
legal framework from substituted
decisions to supported decisions and I
thought most importantly today to use my
time to give you examples of how this
legislation could impact my practice
we've heard testimony from a parent to
parents what seeking guardianship has
done and the process how difficult that
was I've had the opportunity to
represent a number of parents and
guardianships and also represent
proposed Wards and the common issue we
see among parents facing an individual
child turning age 18 is really anguish
about the guardianship process
guardianship about the court the the
difficulty with the court process and
having to go through a Litany of a
child's deficits I think of two cases I
have where there is a guardianship in
place but with the passage of this bill
I think there's a potential to revisit
the need for a continued guardianship
one of these individuals is involved in
a life skill training course and she's
been very very successful another indiv
individual shows the ability to her own
on her own initiative reach out to other
professionals to get information to make
decisions an
example that really goes to what
representative Gordon raised is one
where my colleague had a case where we
had a very very intelligent client with
sarb baly who had
difficulty communicating his needs and a
parent who is very skilled in
understanding what her child wanted and
understanding his medical history and
this is a case where the parent was a
natural fit for the
supporter like attorney skibby I acted
as a caretaker for my own mother and I
look at how this legislation could have
impacted that
relationship and though I had the
ability to act as her supporter and did
so what I found was mostly often in a
busy Medical Practice what happened to
me as the person acting as the helper
everyone naturally looked to me to make
the decisions and the focus was not on
my mother what this legislation would do
is make clear I'm the supporter and this
is the decision maker and while I was
able to redirect the providers I think
that this kind of contract and this
statute would
enable and
support a further shift in our legal
system from substituted decisionmaking
to supported decision-making finally
what I thought about with this testimony
today is just um so pleased to be able
to practice law in New Hampshire and I
thought about other states have adopted
this legislation but you look at our
state with this proud and long tradition
of respecting rights of
individuals and promoting
self-determination and I believe that
house bill 540 really is the next step
in the evolution of our law to actively
promote and honor the ability of all
persons and what better State than the
Live Free or Die State thank you you
very much are there any questions from
Miss
Jones zingan thank you for your
testimony today and the last person who
pre-registered to testify is Lisa
Bowden good morning or good afternoon at
this point
um thank you it's um been an exciting
opportunity for AEL New Hampshire to um
work with um all the stakeholders who
brought forward this and we um
appreciate that um representative Chase
is sponsoring this bill and all the work
that um Mike skibby and the other um
folks who who worked to get this
legislation moved forward um my name is
Lisa Bodwin I'm the executive director
of AEL New Hampshire and I appreciate
your time and attention on House Bill
540 a bill to create and establish the
supported decision-making model here in
New Hampshire on behalf of able its's
board and members across the beautiful
Granite State I'm asking you to support
HB
540 as you know RSA
171a established New Hampshire's
community-based system of supports and
services for people with developmental
disabilities a key element of having a
community-based life is the ability to
be
self-determining supported
decisionmaking um is an important viable
alternative to guardianship which
advances the development of skills for
self-determination um it was nice to
hear attorney Jones just now reference
how New Hampshire has been at the
Forefront of asserting rights for people
with disabilities you all know that New
Hampshire closed its state institution
30 years ago in the effort to advance
human rights for people with
disabilities essentially to make real
the opportunity for these citizens to
access the American dream too supported
decisionmaking is yet another tool in
the quest to fully
include uh uh people with disabilities
these Americans in the
dream supported decision-making is a
process that facilitates people to
become and remain more integrated in the
community more importantly research
shows that this model increases
protection against abuse and
exploitation just a couple of more
points on why supported decision making
is important it's a means to empower
people with disabilities and the Aging
to remain at the center of
decision-making processes in their lives
research also shows that maximizing
choice and control in a person's life
increases positive Health outcomes
happiness and safety through stronger
relationships and better ability to
recognize and resist
abuse uh and one of the reasons why
supported decision- making appeals to me
personally as a parent and not just as a
professional is the idea that support
decision making is normal most people
use informal supports in making personal
decisions just like you and I we seek
the advice of trusted friends Andor
family on medical Financial personal
professional and other issues let's
create a structure for people with
disabilities to have what's typical
please support HB
540 supported decision making will
enhance dignity for people with
disabilities
hell thank you did you thank you I'm
thank
you okay any any questions for Miss
Bowden
being none thank you for your testimony
today and that that concludes the people
who pre-registered is there anyone else
uh any any attendee who wishes to
testify there are a couple of hands
there's a Cheryl
Steinberg we over on our time so if you
could keep your testimony s Sy that
would be very
appreciated yes I can you hear me we can
okay yeah I'll be very brief I
appreciate U my name is Cheryl Steinberg
I am the director of the senior law
project at New Hampshire legal
assistance and I'm here today to testify
in support of House Bill
540 you've already heard all the reasons
why it should be a good thing and I I
support all those all those reasons that
have already been um mentioned and and I
I was on the work group that helped
draft the bill I I think it was very um
well thought out and well reasoned and I
would just say in my experience um of
over 20 years working U with older
adults I can absolutely see the need for
this and um the value um I've talked to
many people who are kind of in this in
between you know able to make some
decisions and not others and they're
under a Guardianship and I could tell
you how distressing it is for them I
mean if you can just even imagine the
the the distress when you might have to
tell a parent um you can't drive anymore
we're taking the carck keys away I mean
how devastating that one act is um it
just to have a guardianship um where you
can't even make any decisions for
yourself um how distressing that could
be so any kind of tool that we can have
at our disposal when appropriate to
allow um uh people to maintain their
decision- making um ability I think is
is a good thing and I'll just end there
I just uh would urge you to vote off to
pass on the bill thank you for your
succinct testimonies appreciated and are
there any questions for Miss
Steinberg Zan thank you and Diane
Bessie can you hear me now we can great
thank you so much thank you chairman
Gordon and the entire Judiciary
Committee for allowing me to speak today
as the executive director of the Monarch
School of New England and approved
private special education school for
children with disabilities located in
Rochester I am pleased to support hb4
540 and the concept of supported
decisionmaking as an alternative to
guardianship over the past 23 years I
have had the pleasure of working with
many parents and students preparing for
the transition to adulthood it is a
stressful and busy time for all parents
and students that face many decisions
ahead since we work with students and
their families for a number of years we
develop trusting relationships over time
as a school we work hard to instill
Independence at every level of function
teaching our students to self- Advocate
whenever possible we presume competence
and concentrate on what a student can do
on their abilities rather than their
disabilities it is simply joyous to
facilitate a student's development from
complete dependence to
self-confidence when students learn to
communicate their thoughts and feelings
and understanding the possibilities are
endless while guardianship is
appropriate for some students for others
who are able to self-determine their
path ahead with or without the guidance
of a trusted individual supported
decision- making allows them the freedom
and Independence they should have in
making choices in how to live their
lives because we want families to be
fully informed as students reach the age
of majority the Monarch School of New
England looks forward to sharing
materials developed by the New Hampshire
Department of Education that will
clearly outline all options along the
Continuum including power of attorney
conservatorship guardianship and and SDM
while it is true that IEP teams have the
most contact with students with
disabilities and their parents making
the IEP team appear to be the ideal
entity to share these options in our
experience sometimes parents select to
work outside of the IEP team with area
agencies or caregivers from a Community
Mental Health Center to carry out this
critical step
while um these entities will follow
students until the age of 21 while
school districts will not would it not
make sense to hold other enti entities
responsible as well for presenting And
discussing the options
available I do not want to see any
individual with a disability fall
through the cracks yet as an
administrator I fear any consequences
should a school inadvertently fail to
inform the family of the choices other
than guardianship because so much is
going on at this busy juncture in a
student's life thank you for the
opportunity to testify testify in
support of HB 540 I look forward to
watching HB 540 continue to develop
bringing greater opportunity to students
with individuals with disabilities I'm
sorry and greater control over their own
lives and I'm happy to answer any
questions that you may have are there
any questions from Miss
Bessie see none thank you for your
testimony
today and I see no other hands up among
our attendees and I will declare the
hearing closed on House Bill
540 oh I'm sorry I forgot the the my
promise to let you testify
representative McBeth sorry go
ahead I'm I'm a little bit intimidated
because I think all the people that
presented testimony before um the
practitioners have more experience years
of experience than I do in this area and
the um people with personal experiences
um certainly had a lot of impact I just
I I do practice in this area just had a
a wonderful hearing this morning on a
petition for guardianship in the uh
Brentwood Probate Court um I want to let
you know that um for those of you that
don't and I Wendy would you hold your
hand up at three minutes so I know when
I'm done but I do see this I I'm
speaking in favor of this idea um I
don't see it as a replacement for
guardianship I definitely see it as a
good alternative I want to assure
everyone that New Hampshire 20 years ago
was on on The Cutting Edge of our
guardianship uh law we make it so that
every guardianship is tailored and I I
can use a prop this is a page just one
of the four pages on a petition for
Guardianship and there are specific
every right civil right that's removed
from somebody and it is removing a civil
right and transferred to the guardian
has to be written in the petition and an
attorney Like Me by Statute is appointed
to discuss it with that proposed Ward um
and even this morning after the petition
was granted on the on the limited issues
um that were either contested or not
contested the judge did say reads from
the and explains to the guardian that
they are under fiduciary responsibility
to safeguard to the greatest extent
possible even in the rights they've been
given transferred that they must
Safeguard the GU this the wards rights
so I just want to say that but I want to
tell you this is the top of the petition
ition and it is very difficult for me to
go and talk to somebody and tell them
that a petition for guardianship
declaiming them as an incapacitated
person is is not always appropriate and
what also is not always appropriate what
we've had testimony is this removal of
all self-determination from that person
um even people that need help
um I I um it is an
adversarial um proceeding and the person
that is under a guardianship is known
from there on out on every form as the
ward which can be really really
inappropriate and two instances of this
are um you know A 42-year-old that I
worked with years ago that had a
motorcycle accident paralyzed from the
neck down he's not an incapacitated
person he's a person that has needs
needs supported decision making but
anyway he was you know those were our
options um you also are talking about
people that even if they might be able
to be trained in technology these are
people that don't have the resources for
that and in New Hampshire we we don't
provide those resources another
guardianship a 60-year-old woman who had
cerebral paly when she was younger I
mean when at Birth and had never had a
guardian 60 years old but because of
her um I think really her presence her
the way she presented herself and her
inability to communicate clearly to
people
a guardianship was really the only
option she had because a lot of the
communication is by phone she wasn't
able to travel places because of lack of
Transportation so again I'm I am really
supporting this as an option um I do um
I'm very interested by attorney
Zachary's comments about removing the
disability because when I think of my
mom and how much I'd like to um help her
and be a supportive decision-making
she's not she's 85 she's not under a
disability any disability except maybe
insecurity because she lives in a youth
centered culture and also because she
has anxiety around some technology um so
I um I I see this as the reason why a
guardianship is so powerful it's it's
and why I think this would be and it
goes back to uh chair Gordon's comment
this really authorizes people the the
professionals it it makes it okay for
agencies and entities to share
information with another person um and
and that's one of the reasons
particularly in the 60-year-old woman
that I was talking about she was getting
run over by agencies and people and she
needed an advocate that had a paper that
said you have to listen to me so anyway
I'm I'm so grateful that we're talking
about this I think it's so important and
I um I I I'm I I think there's some
things that might need to be worked on
but I just um I'm thrilled to have it in
a toolkit for uh the citizens of New
Hampshire so thank you and I know I
spoke more than three minutes I
apologize byebye well thank you for your
enthusiasm so and um is there are there
any questions for representative
MCB and seeing none will'll close the
hearing on House Bill
540 we will recess and reconvene at one
o'clock thank you
everybody thank you Mr
chair
for
e
s
[Music]
for
we just
done
morning
very good chance
that
minutes told me they saw me on
T see me I just can't answer
that
really
well the worst part of it it didn't even
have a
be
well near the
[Music]
end so since
we leadership
de
no have to
answer Mr
welper yes this is Mark page I just want
to let you know you're um not muted on
the
on the
Judiciary I didn't even think I can you
hear me now I can hear you
yes I just want to let you know I didn't
know if that was I just want to let you
know
sorry
good afternoon
everyone we'll call this meeting of the
house Judiciary Committee back to
order and
our work for this afternoon is a hearing
on House Bill
440 relative to the protection of
religious
liberty the primary sponsor of that bill
is representative Jim
kofalt and representative kofalt would
you like to introduce your
bill
and I need to be made a host I think in
order to
allow representative Kofa there we
go
representative kofalt you're on thank
you thank you Mr chairman can you hear
me we
can thank you uh so HP 440 um is H is a
bill to protect religious liberty in New
Hampshire um and I also want to direct
your attention to the fact that I have
been discussing a proposed amendment
with representative Sylvia which I
believe he has uh shared with the rest
of you um so I will speak to the
original bill and the uh the proposed
amendment as well here if I
may um so uh James Madison the architect
of our federal free exercise clause
wrote that the right to free exercise of
religion is held by the same tenure with
all of our other rights uh the intention
of this bill is to ensure that that
intent is honored in the state of New
Hampshire um in effect it it directs
judges to treat part one Article 5 of
our state constitution as an enforceable
legal right um and um you know you one
may ask why that's necessary um and and
essentially it it comes down to the fact
that in some judges Chambers around the
country uh there has been a school of
thought that holds that constitutional
protections for religion should be
viewed as a matter of preference not
necessarily A strictly enforceable right
and so the intention of this bill has
been to uh to underscore legislative
intent uh to treat religious liberty as
a uh as a as a strictly interpreted
constitutional
right uh fortunately our our state
supreme court um has has not taken that
view uh that I mentioned earlier they
have come down uh firmly on the side of
religious
liberty um on December 22nd after this
bill was filed the Supreme Court decided
the case of New Hampshire versus Mack
and in that decision they asserted the
right to free exercise of religion
stating that part one Article 5 must be
applied by New Hampshire judges and so
in essence what that ruling does is it
provides the protection that this bill
was intended to
guarantee so we could potentially
proceed with this bill as a sort of a
statutory fallback to the Court's
decision that wouldn't necessarily be a
bad thing however um there's another
concern that that has come up that I I
think uh really is required in order for
us to underscore this uh protection of
religious liberty and frankly for that
matter all other civil liberties
guaranteed under the US and New
Hampshire
constitutions um the proposed amendment
addresses the question of whether
constitutional rights may be suspended
during a time of Crisis and although
that may sound like an unlikely scenario
it is actually the current state of the
law right now in New Hampshire in 2020
the New Hampshire Superior Court issued
a ruling in which they stated and I
quote
the governor May suspend or limit
constitutional rights during a state of
emergency so looking around New
Hampshire you might not guess that we're
living in a world where where
constitutional rights uh can be
suspended um churches are not closed
guns have not been
confiscated and citizens are not being
pulled off the street and held without
due process however uh we are somewhat
interestingly living in a situation
right now in which the state of New
Hampshire takes the position that we do
not have enforcable legal rights under
the US and state
constitutions when a governor issues
emergency orders he acts under the
emergency Powers delegated to him under
RSA 445 and
47 the proposed amendment simply add a
clarification and I would direct you to
section six of the proposed amendment
which really contains the the relevant
language here it's two short paragraphs
and they are almost a repeat of each
other uh the proposed amendment simply
adds the clarification that quote civil
liberties shall on no account be
suspended nor shall the United States
Constitution or the New Hampshire Bill
of Rights be suspended set aside or
infringed so that is a very uh narrowly
defined uh
clarification very limited in scope um
clarifying the legislator's intent
concerning the governor's emergency
powers that would bring us into the
company of multiple other jurisdictions
around the country including
Maine uh the governor currently has
enumerated powers actually very flexible
enumerated powers to deal with an
emergency and this would not change that
it would simply ensure that in
challenges to any of the governor's
actions or any future Governor's actions
the courts would need to conduct an
ordinary constitutional analysis rather
than simply declaring that civil
liberties are suspended and with that I
uh I will take any questions
yes representative
Horan now I'm unmuted oh thank you very
much Mr chair and thank you rent kall
for taking my question um you had a
quote from James Madison um which I
guess is something you're planning to is
a quote from something called the
memorial and remonstrance against
religious assessments um so what's which
is actually it's not in the amendment
but what's the
uh what was that in the what was the
larger context for that like what was
that um what was the large what was of
course relig in a religious assessment
sounds like uh I know New Hampshire and
most other states like the state used to
support at least certain religions which
they don't directly do anymore although
um we do get property tax exemptions and
other benefits so what what was the
context for that quote you started out
with
um to be to be honest I I I don't I put
together my notes uh some time ago and I
don't recall the exact context of
that okay fair enough a followup um and
so what the definition I mean like I see
St with religious organizations and
religion so what's what's to stop just
somebody from just creating a uh
creating just any type of organization
and calling it a religious organization
and then thus exempting themselves from
Rel lease uh
some laws so like where's the where's
the where's the protection the so what
that's that's a great question um there
have and so as I was as I was
researching uh some of the case law
surrounding um surrounding religious
liberty that is one concern or objection
that comes up fairly frequently um in in
actual case law however um we don't we
we have not seen that happen um in other
words the the courts have uh have done a
a fairly good job of distinguishing
between um or quite a good job I would
say of distinguishing between uh
Bonafide religious uh religious liberty
cases and um you know in in cases in
which someone comes up with uh sort of
using religious liberty as as kind of a
shield for uh for activity that would
otherwise be
prohibited okay thank you very much
thanks representative
Kelly thank you Mr chair and um thank
you for taking my question
representative kofalt um could you give
a specific example of the kind of future
case you're worried might happen if
civil liberties can be
suspended well um I I can tell you that
you know in in the case of religious
liberty generally speaking um the the
Mac case actually is is which I I
mentioned uh in my testimony is actually
an interesting example because that was
an example pertaining to the religious
use of psilocybe and mushrooms which are
psychedelic and um in this case uh the
defendant was um actually was part of a
legitimate uh Bonafide
religious um organization that that uh
used those in you know as part of their
uh religious ritual R and ceremonies um
and so you know this this was where um I
mean the distinction really is that the
the state must make a compelling case
there if if an activity is otherwise
prohibited um such as the use of
psilocybin mushrooms um if a case is
otherwise
prohibited um or generally prohibited I
should say um the the the Supreme Court
rulings uh throughout most of of history
have taken the position that um
religious liberty would Prevail unless
the state can demonstrate a compelling
interest um in the prohibition um so uh
in that case there was not a compelling
interest in the prohibition I think
there have been some concerns about uh
prohibitions on uh religious gatherings
um during emergencies um the the the
bill actually would not the the bill was
not intended uh as as originally written
was not ever intended to uh to to stand
in the way of of those uh but uh there
there have been other CA there's there's
been other case law um one and I'm I'm
trying to remember the uh the citation
but there was a Supreme Court case
involving the collection of sales taxes
um in Utah when someone was selling
religious pamphlets and tracks and uh
they claimed exemption from sales tax
because it was uh a religious activity
uh it went to the US Supreme Court and
the Supreme Court ruled that um there
was ultimately a uh a compelling uh
there was not ultimately a compelling
State interest and um that it was
protected religious activity protected
from sales tax um there was a similar
case involving a um a a a plaintiff who
who sued a state that had denied her uh
Unemployment uh claims because she was a
Seventh Day Adventist she refused to
work on Sunday she was fired from her
job went to collect unemployment and was
told that um you know you you you don't
really get unemployment and uh because
you you refused to work on Sunday and so
again the state was unable to
demonstrate a compelling State interest
in uh in in in in the position of not
paying unemployment in that case so
these are these some of the kind of uh
borderline cases again the Mac decision
effectively establishes um a clear you
know a a clear line for how those should
be decided which is that they should
come down on the side of religious
liberty the concern is that we are
living in a situation right now under uh
under the Superior Court decision from
last year that effectively says quote
civil liberty um the the governor may
let me find the quote the governor May
suspend or limit constitutional rights
during a state of emergency that calls
into question all of our constitutional
rights um and you know in that respect
you know this really is you know it
remains uh a a protection of religious
liberty but in many respects it is a uh
a protection of of all civil liberties
um by clarifying the legislator's intent
that emergency powers are not intended
to um to to allow the government to
override suspend or limit constitutional
rights um I have just one more quick
question um if I may uh is there a
possibility that even if this bill
passes with the amendment um a governor
could still suspend Civ civil liberties
under a theory of inherent
powers
um I I don't know um I I actually I know
that there is uh someone who I think was
trying to sign up to testify I believe
he was not he he he called me shortly
before this hearing and told me that he
was unable to uncheck the Box uh
indicating that he was he wants to
testify um Ian hwit is uh should be on
the line and and probably raising his
hand uh but he would be the better
person to ask that question I
think very good thank
you representative
Burch thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
my question is a followup a bit to
representative Horgan's question and
also your most recent uh uh
responses
um I read the Mad case a little
differently than you do
but uh isn't it
true
that the New Hampshire Supreme Court
basically said that anyone can can
entertain what religious thoughts they
wish and make a religion out of them and
that the courts can't step in and decide
what's theologically correct and what's
theologically uh
nonsense um again I would I would
perhaps defer to attorney huitt on the
on on a more detailed analysis of that
my understanding of the Court's position
is that it is not their uh place to
determine uh the the theological
correctness but it it is their their
position that they may uh determine what
is a a legitimate Bonafide uh religious
uh activity versus uh versus what is not
but I I would ultimately defer to uh to
Ian hu on that
one if I could follow up
um actually I think in the in the MA
case the uh it was stipulated that this
was a Bonafide religious practice the
the the cocy and stuff my question to
you further is you talked about the tax
people in Utah uh not wanting to pay the
sales tax or or whatever kind of tax you
refer to um would your bill affect a
situation that has arisen in in my neck
of the Woods in New Hampshire where um
uh I say this without any negative
connotation the free Staters uh in in
our area uh decided uh in order to uh
not pay property taxes to incorporate
themselves as a church and did so and
gave themselves uh religious titles and
then litigated with the town of Keen or
city of Kean whether they would have to
pay uh uh taxes or not uh are you
suggesting uh that this legislation of
yours um would bless that to use that
term would bless that effort uh and that
perhaps we could all uh turn our homes
into churches and avoid paying uh
property
taxes
uh this this legislation as amended
would would actually not do any such
thing it it it would be quite narrow in
Focus as I said it would establish that
the governor May under no circumstances
limit or suspend constitutional rights
under under the emergency Powers um in
RSA 445 and 47 so it it really it it it
pertains um as as it is written right
now or written in the amend mment uh it
it would it would pertain specifically
to um the the question of whether the
emergency Powers may be suspended or
whether constitutional rights may be
suspended or limited under under the
emergency power
statute thank
you are there any other questions for
representative
Kofa seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today thank you
and uh I think since we're talking about
a potential Amendment I'm going to call
upon representative Sylvia next and he
can address the amendment I
think sorry thank you Mr chairman
um representative kofalt brought this
idea to me and I certainly uh am very
much supportive of this um where he
initially started out in uh part for
Article Five I think we can now look to
part first article 10 where we uh affirm
the the rights of uh all people in the
State uh without regard to any special
classes of U men or people or or even
religions so um I I fully support this
uh Amendment and I I think it's a great
uh tool particularly in the case of
these emergency powers that we uh we
need to be able to uh challenge any
unconstitutional um orders produced by
the
executive any questions for
representative
Sylvia representative syia if I just
that the amendment and I'm sorry I don't
have it in front of me and I'm afraid to
go
out of the zoom and do that because I'm
afraid I'll screw up my zoom connection
but uh so I'm just asking did the U the
amendment I thought I heard them say at
the beginning that the amendment would
replace bill as it's currently written
correct and I also think I heard it said
that the amendment was just two
paragraphs is that uh so there is a lot
of preamble to it uh the first five
sections and then uh section six and
seven get down to uh the actual
statutory
language um so there's uh there's just a
couple of sections
that revolve around the emergency Powers
acts okay thank you representative
Horgan thank you very much Mr chair
thank you siia um
do you feel like expounding on which of
the uh urgency Powers were
unconstitutional and which aren't um so
like what exactly was it based on an
experience over the last year that
you're trying to prevent from happening
in future should you know we have
another uh pandemic or other catastrophe
that you know kills half a million
Americans between 12200 here in the US
so which one any that you're
particularly concerned about in
particular thank you thank you for the
question representative Oregan um I
think that there is a there is a fairly
serious question about the ability of
the legislature to delegate powers to
make law and that uh that question is
part of a one of the
remonstrances and frankly we should take
it up and we should uh make clear
whether or not uh the the delegation of
that Authority is actually within the
Constitution and uh
perhaps attorney huitt when he comes up
will maybe address that a little
bit um okay I I get it I mean this is I
don't want to get in territory we would
want to with the excutive session but uh
I guess is it uh isn't true the
legislature did eventually find a way to
uh come back um within you know within
three months of when the pandemic was
and they probably were trying to do it
earlier
or so Greek so you how do you feel so do
you have any comment on on that aspect
of the fact that you know at least and
there are like some legislative like
there for example The Joint fiscal
committee attempted to continue did
continue meeting but then the uh
Governor never referred any of the uh
emergency uh expenditures to it that's a
little bit off the topic of religious
liberty but right well as as the bill is
amended um when when the legislature
comes
back a lot of these uh emergency orders
um could be done
legislatively and obviously it's a much
slower
process so the ability for the governor
act we went uh you know a couple hundred
years without these this this statute uh
RSA 445 446 447 I'll be speaking to 446
next Friday I believe
and we we managed to get by we managed
to get through the Civil War we got
through the Spanish Flu we got through
World War I World War
II um we managed to keep the state from
falling apart and I think that a lot of
this is uh unnecessary and
superflous thank
I could just jump in with a question
representative
Sylvia
if uh and
and and that is I you know I can I can
agree with you that there needs to be
changes in emergency powers and my
understanding is the only reason the
governor has emergency Powers is because
we've statutorily given him those
emergency Powers so why
uh and I I guess the question ultimately
comes down to this why not address the
concerns that have been expressed in
terms of changing the governor's
emergency powers or limiting them as
opposed to this approach which seems
more
heavy-handed thank you for the question
Mr chairman um I I think we've been
wrestling for quite some time about how
to
uh get this whole system to work where
everybody is uh in agreement and I think
we're a long way away from that
um I don't
know this is this is our I guess best
attempt at coming up with something that
will be
workable representative
Burch
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question I
was looking at the language in section
seven saying that uh it provided that
civil liberty shall not otherwise be
infringed in the time of emergency so
let's say there's a mammoth flood in
conquered and it's just a tremendous
human disaster and an an emergency is
going on and the governor wishes to
say uh no uh large groups of people
Shall Gather in the center part of of
conquer because it's a disaster
area are you suggesting by this bill
that the governor should not be allowed
that
power actually I I would uh I would say
yes I mean let's look at uh
if we use your example we can look at uh
Katrina and the uh the flood there there
was that uh those folks that came out
with their boats to come to the rescue
and they were stopped from uh assisting
uh so we might have a large group of
people coming together to help and the
governor perhaps one person making that
decision is not necessarily the smartest
person sorry to say not speaking to
anyone in
particular uh so these things with the
top- down central control
uh I'm not sure that we really want
that I've got no further
questions any other questions for
representative
sovet yes representative
Chase
so are you just you're saying
that in a disaster or where other
people's Health can be affected
that you feel it's the right to still be
able to congregate
together basically is what I'm asking
you because I could go on and on but you
understand what I'm saying you just
override I I do and actually the there
the Constitution does speak in one
section about um Health
emergencies and there there is a time
and a place for
quarantines um so that is a power that's
in the Constitution that the governor
has but it's it's limited
and U I think the current situation uh
in my opinion does not reach the level
of an
emergency
okay thank you thank you for the
question okay any any other questions
for representative
Sylvia seean thank you for your
testimony thank
you we have uh seven several people who
have pre uh we have a couple of people
who have pre-registered to testify
today uh one being Susan
price well miss
price I think I'm unmuted you are oh
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members um my name is Susan price I live
in
molor I do support this bill I have not
seen the amendment so I'll only be
speaking to the uh the primary Bill my
focus is on essential
Services um those who do not
um belong to a church or actively
involved in a church may not understand
that churches provide services Beyond
direct
Ministry uh in the religious
sense um so my focus and the reason I
support this bill is
because churches need to in times of
Crisis provide many essential
Services uh the New Hampshire food bank
is oper ated by Capital uh Catholic
Charities imagine if Catholic Charities
had not been able to operate that
essential service I think the New
Hampshire food bank is an essential
service the same with the Salvation Army
they have a very large facility in
lonia so there seems to be a
misunderstanding in the secular
population that churches do not provide
essential services there seems to be
this Focus that going to church on
Sunday and going through uh whatever
denomination you are or your synagogue
or your mosque that those entities only
provide direct um religious Services
when that could be the furthest from
reality unfortunately due to the
governor's order many smaller churches
including the one that we attend in
Molen Boro the United Methodist church
we were forced down forced to close our
doors and we could not provide essential
Community Services many of which that
are provided to
non-members so that's the reason I'm
supporting the bill I seriously you know
in all practicality I don't think it's
going to make it past the governor uh
but I do think it warrants a discussion
and um more like a a teaching lesson for
people who do not really understand how
churches essentially serve their
communities Beyond uh showing up on
Sunday morning at 10:
a.m. so um thank you for your time and I
hope you'll consider my
comments Miss Bry are there any
questions from Miss
pry say none thank you again for your
testimony today thank you uh the only
only other person who pre-registered to
testify is Nathaniel Diaz Rua and I'm
looking but I don't see his name on the
list of
attendees so I will call on other people
there are some other attendees who do uh
wish to speak uh one of them one of whom
has already been mentioned that's Ian
huitt
good afternoon Mr chairman can you hear
me we can
fantastic well I hope I can help provide
some clarity here there's been a lot of
discussion of religious liberty um and
of the Mac decision and I I do believe
that the Mac decision provides the
protections that are in the Bill as
amended and so for that reason um I
think that this discussing excuse me not
the bill as amended but the bill as
originally written and so for that
reason I think probably discussing the
bill as originally written might not be
the best overall use of our time um you
know I I certainly am passionate about
and focus on religious liberty and so if
there are questions about whether
religious liberty is a workable right
I'm happy to discuss those but the Mac
decision does already provide um those
exact protections for religious liberty
so if there are questions about the bill
as introduced then then those same
questions would apply to the macis
itself the the amendment as I understand
it would wholesale replace the text of
the original bill and I think if any
representative ever has a good excuse
and reason to do that representative
kofalt does as the Supreme Court after
he had introduced the bill issued a
decision providing the protections that
were in the bill as introduced so I
think he has a good reason to use this
bill to address a a related but larger
problem the the problem that's addressed
by this amendment is not not religious
liberty or or Gatherings or another
partisan issue the problem is that our
Superior Court cases are pretty clear in
saying that during a state of emergency
if someone brings any kind of
constitutional Challenge and that may
not be religious liberty that may not be
about Gatherings it could be about
speech the courts will simply not do a
constitutional analysis I think if
members of this committee read through
some of the reasoning in the superior
Court's been decision I think some
members on both sides will be quite
alarmed the court there was quite
explicit in saying that under our
current emergency Powers constitutional
analysis simply doesn't apply under con
any constitutional challenge du an
emergency order the court will simply
ask whether there's a factual some
factual basis connecting the order to
the state of emergency and if it was in
good faith uh that allows virtually any
right uh to be infringed and and the
court was very explicit about this now I
disagree in part with something
representative Sylvia said I don't agree
that if we change our emergency Powers
law so that constitutional rights can't
be suspended that will mean the governor
can never prohibit Gatherings New
Hampshire is in the minority in that our
courts have said constitutional rights
can be suspended what many other courts
are doing in Maine for example is saying
constitutional rights can't be suspended
in a time of emergency but these
emergency orders pass constitutional
muster emergency orders limiting
Gatherings and things so we would not
have chaos in our state if we affected
this change we would be in the same
position as Maine which has a somewhat
lower case count than us by the way and
if I could I'll just walk through a
specific hypothetical of how what I
would characterize is an abusive case
could easily play out um under our
current law so suppose five or 10 years
from now there were a legitimate
emergency
in New Hampshire and let's say that the
governor decided on the basis of a good
faith belief that media coverage of that
emergency was causing alarm um in the
state so the governor issued an order
under his emergency Powers saying that
media in New Hampshire simply may not
cover or report on the emergency and
let's say the union leader or someone
sought an injunction under the First
Amendment challenge that the analysis
that our Superior Courts have used in
for example the bford case is just
twofold is there a factual basis
connecting the order to the state of
emergency and was it in good faith so in
my hypothetical where if the union
leader seeks that injunction there is a
factual basis no doubt about that um
it's connected to the state of emergency
and we've stipulated the governor in
good faith believes media coverage is
causing um harm and panic so the court
would simply as a matter of course um
then dismiss that suit it would apply
apply no First Amendment analysis now
under ordinary constitutional analysis
what the court would do there is would
it would say this is a Content
discriminatory order so we're going to
apply strict scrutiny but under the
suspension of civil liberties Theory
that's that's current in our Superior
Courts that analysis simply wouldn't
happen so the governor can do these
other things the governor can try to
limit Gatherings the governor could do
everything the governor in Maine is
doing right now the the concern is
potential future situations where the
governor would have effectively
Unlimited power um I recognize some of
these specific issues uh you know
religious Liberties Gatherings maybe
Second Amendment issues are more
partisan but I think if there is one
civil liberties issue where there could
be some bipartisan support it should be
on this question of whether civil
liberties in their entirety May simply
be declared suspended and whether courts
can say we simply aren't going to do an
analysis of these Liberties in a state
of emergency and and the last thing I'll
say and I'll take any questions is in
response to something chairman Gordon
said um you know just putting aside the
original language what this bill as
amended would do is precisely amend our
emergency power statutes um I I agree
with you chairman Gordon the the
Superior Courts have uh have said that
they are reaching these conclusions
under the current emergency power
statute so we could amend 4 colon 45 and
4on 47 to say the governor has these
very flexible enumerated powers in a
state of emergency provided that civil
liberties may not be suspended and what
that means is not that the governor
can't limit Gatherings can't can't do
all kinds of things that most governors
in other states are doing it simply
means that when um specific orders are
challenged the courts will do the normal
constitutional analysis um under those
challenges instead of just saying you
don't have these rights right now so
that that's the goal of this bill as as
amended um I hope it's it's possible to
have at least some bipartisan support
and I'll say lastly if if there is any
member of this committee who suspects
that the amendment really is a back door
for some more partisan issue I hope
you'll you'll question me about that we
can start that discussion and that a
chance to explain why that's not the
case and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you representative Oregan well
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
much attorney uh attorney H at
guess I'll do a couple link together a
couple of non-hypothetical cases that
happened up here in Northern New England
the first part of it was there was a
religious gathering in U Central Maine
guess it was a uh a wedding ceremony I
believe which I guess is not necessarily
a religious gathering but this one was
and uh large number of people attended
um
apparently without observing the uh
various precautions that are taken more
for granted now than they were this
summer and which aren't and um so that
those people who attended it caused um
you know caused hundreds of other covid
cases including a number of deaths you
know quite far a field from the
Gathering probably some even in New
Hampshire I know for example caused an
outbreak at um I think New York County
Prison which is which is a county that
ad joins my county and then subsequently
so the second non-hypothetical case
which is ISU the same issue as we had a
a representative from dipit had a uh
basically a Tent Revival on his property
and sent uh then they sent people out
to and then they sent attendees at the
tent Gathering went out to other other
homes in New Hampshire Massachusetts Pro
ties and there was controversy over how
to address that so um so do you are you
are you so do you feel that um religious
organizations should be held to a lower
standard for those type of precautions
than um non-religious organizations
would who also are peacefully assembling
for whatever purpose they're assembling
for well there is a distinct right for
religious gatherings um you know there
there are rights General rights to
assembly in our constitution but you
know there are specific rights for the
free exercise of religion whereas
there's not specifically uh enumerated
rights for like a labor organization
organize so there is a special right
that can be applied in those sorts of
cases that you could bring a free a
state free EXC challenge under now the
Mac decision so that's already in place
now I I think the question and issue
here is if let's say I were to represent
one of those religious groups and sue
for an injunction under the free
exercise clause would the courts um
apply the ordinary free exercise
analysis under the Mac decision and if
they did that doesn't automatically mean
they would allow the Gatherings the
court would just ask is this narrowly
tailored to achieve a compelling
government purpose just just the
ordinary constitutional analysis but
under a suspension theory in a state of
emergency the court would apply no
constitutional analysis it would say
this is an emergency this is a good
faith action um this is connected to the
state of emergency and I'm going to
throw this case out um now I will tell
you setting aside what I think should
happen I think it it just is correct
that if our courts were instructed under
this amendment to do regular
Constitution analysis I do think that in
the situation you're describing our
Superior Courts would find that the
orders were constitutional I happen to
think that the orders that were
challenged in Binford itself actually
were constitutional and I think if the
court had just done an ordinary
constitutional analysis it would have
upheld those orders what's troubling is
the precedent these courts have set by
saying constitutional rights flat out
don't apply and we just won't do
analysis and and that applies not just
to cases representative oron where you
and I might disagree like religious
gatherings but all other kinds of civil
liberties cases for Fourth Amendment
cases um in bford the the court
mentioned it quoted an 11 circuit case
um AO I believe and in that case and in
the quotation from that case the court
was quite explicit that the first
amendment is among the rights that can
be suspended including just you know
ordinary speech rights um so the the
idea that civil liberties can be
suspended in an emergency undermines all
of our enumerated civil liberties rights
including some where I expect we would
agree and not just these religious
gatherings
tyan are you okay oh well I'm fine but
I've got a follow followup please um
course this is also a political rather
than
constitutional um question and I
probably a little bit outside this bill
but do you think we need to recalibrate
sort of the relationship between church
and state like James Madison's name came
up at the beginning and controversy in
that case was uh you know churches were
directly subsidized by the state in fact
they were part of the state and they
provided they Alli them for a lot more
range of services than they are now and
then um Susan price who came by by way
is a former State Rep from barington who
since moved to Bolton bro but um she
pointed out that her church in in
molteno U you know provides a lot of uh
services and then gets for example prop
and then she didn't mention get property
tax exemptions a variety of other
subsidies from the state you think
perhaps would be good idea moving
forward to deal with perhaps to uh
reduce the subsidies and um and perhaps
increase the secular sector I guess is
probably you're horrified by that
suggestion but I I'll bring it up anyway
I don't know that I'm horrified in it I
guess I would just say I'm much less
interested in these Establishment Clause
questions than free exercise the
questions that I work on with
Cornerstone in the Constitutional area
tend to be free exercise question and I
I think that was the origin of that
Madison quotation in the original bill
is is yes is just that Madison was
saying that the the free exercise right
which Madison drafted by the way should
be enforcable like any other right but
but of course all of that language
specific to religious liberty will be a
moved by by the amendment um and the the
amendment will simply broadly address
civil liberties okay
representative M
Kelly thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for taking my question um can you tell
me was the bford case taken to the
Supreme Court no it it wasn't taken to
the Supreme Court um I would say that
there are a few reasons that the house
should go ahead and address this issue
um even though it hasn't yet been taken
into um you know one is that this has
been a very influential case we've seen
it cited in other Superior Court cases
by an influential and respective judge
who's clearly particularly influential
um in the area of of constitutional
rights and how they apply to states of
emergency um Governor suu himself has
repeatedly cited the bford case um in in
his emergency orders and of course this
this was argued um by our solicitor
general the The Briefing calling
explicitly for courts to hold that
constitutional rights can be suspended
in states of emergency was written by
our solicitor general so there there are
you know this is certainly a theory that
has a lot of currency even though it
hasn't been taken up to the Supreme
Court yet um and I I think that it would
be best to rather than waiting for this
to get out of control and for a future
um you know potentially quite intrusive
situation to play out for the house to
act to enact this reasonable limitation
on the scope of the emergency power
statutes that you know would not
undermine most of what the governor is
doing but would just bring us into line
with other states like Maine where
courts are still doing regular
constitutional analysis in these
cases thank you I guess that that begs
my question really and that is as I
understand the amendment again I don't
have the amendment in front of me I'm
sorry but as I heard the testimony the
testimony is that the amendment has a
couple of paragraphs but more
specifically it indicates
that constitutional civil
rights uh will not be set aside or
infringed by the exercise of the
governor's emergency
Powers which is different than the idea
that if the governor does exercise his
emergency powers that affect
constitutional rights that the standard
of review should be put in place that
basically says he has to have a
compelling the state has to prove that
there's a compelling interest to do so
and which seems to have a lot more
appeal to me than the standard that
might be in this amendment and I'm just
wondering if that's something that
possibly could be
changed in time for us to act on this
bill in a timely
manner well Corone would certainly have
no objection to the removal of the word
infringement but I would point out
obviously there are many rights in the
con tion that use that word infringe and
of course what what that means in
practice is is not that if I bring a a
First Amendment case the court you know
automatically as soon as my speech is
burdened it gives me an injunction what
what it means is just that the court
will do ordinary strict scrutiny
analysis and and I also think chairman
Gordon if you read through the the whole
Amendment there's there's a lot of
language about its purpose and I I think
you'll you'll probably agree that the
the purpose of it is just to ensure that
ordinary constitutional analysis
is applied and and not to C certainly
not to enact any higher standard in
times of emergency all of the purpose
oriented language is about fact that the
general court in the in this Bill is
saying it once regular constitutional
scrutiny to be applied but you know at
the same time if if that's a concern
from my perspective taking out the word
infringe wouldn't undermine the
amendment so if if that's something that
would make others more comfortable um
with the bill that's not something that
that certain Cornerstone would
object thank
you there any other questions for Mr
hwood seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you the next person is JR H
Hy good afternoon committee um chairman
Gordon um good to see you um
representative Smith and who else did I
see I saw representative buron there at
one point with a really cool background
for the record um former representative
J.R Hull um currently the secretary for
the New Hampshire Firearms Coalition as
well I speak um both as a citizen as
well as um a board member for the New
Hampshire Firearms Coalition and I want
to talk about both the bill as filed as
well as the amendment so I'm going to do
the bill as
filed
we we think there is value to the bill
as filed I appreciate the case law for
those who are attorneys on on the on in
this meeting you guys love case law
that's great I love statutes but that's
probably due to the fact that I spent
eight years helping write them and I
think citizens go to statutes first then
they do case law so if if there was
still value in having this even though
the Mac decision is is good having case
law in my opinion is is even more
valuable um regarding the so I'm speak
that's for me speaking as as for myself
regarding the amendment I think the
amendment is really really clear in
terms of the changes to RSA 445 and 47
in sections 6 and S of the
amendment that the protections outlined
in the Constitution and be that the
Second Amendment article
2A right be that our our Free Speech
protections should never be um stepped
on even in an
emergency when our Founders drafted the
Constitution they thought about things
like this and it was only the 1980s that
we bothered to strip some of this
language out um article 43 in in part 2
actually removed the the language
infectious deer um from what the
government the governor had authority to
do in
1980 so it was clear that the founders
realized that infectious diseases are in
fact a real issue they need to be dealt
with appropriately and the governor
should be the first one to call the the
legislature back in to session for the
purpose of having policy decided and and
that's an appropriate separation of
powers um if I go to part first there's
there's numerous sections where the
suspension of laws should only be by the
legislature and not by anyone else
um but that's where we are so the
question was raised is this that over
the toop change no I think this is an
appropriate level change to um the eer
Powers know that the governor can always
call the legislature back in the session
and say hey guys we have a problem um
and I could think of problems that
exceed the covid restrictions let's just
say um seabook heaven forbid but C Brook
had a an Emergency shutdown problem and
there was a slow leak whether it was a
leak in the primary Loop or a leak in
the secondary that's a real emergency
and I think everybody on this um that's
participating in this hearing would
understand that that's a real emergency
and the right thing to do would be to
call the legislature back in session
because we may have to move everybody
who's over in that section of the state
away or who knows what
um so it is important that the the
governor call on the legislature but at
no point should we ever allow the
Executive Branch the ability to suspend
our constitutional protections I'm going
to I'm going to use the example um that
attorney huitt hwit just said right
about what if the press was was stirring
up a controversy and the governor just
said arbitrarily well we're going to
prevent them from from participating at
that event my God I can't think of a
worse offense than shutting down the
Free Press if if the Press cannot um
report on what's going on you're going
to get a very biased story from somebody
and it's not going to be the free and
fair
press
so this small change is adequate it's
clear here it it puts and I've seen the
amendment um it puts reasonable
constraints on the the emergency powers
that they are in statute it doesn't
completely repeal them it doesn't
over-the-top wholesale them and change
them dramatically but it does put in
reasonable protections to note that the
rights that are outlined in the
Constitution the doubt the quote Thou
shalt not overstep these bounds unquote
language which is pretty clear in the
Bill of rights is off limits during
these emergency shutdowns or emergency
orders so I would ask that you would
have passed both the bill as filed in my
opinion they should be merged but that's
me as a novice um and there may be
others who have different opinion but at
least sections six and seven should be
added to the original bill because um
our constitutional protections are kind
of the Baseline the foundation of a of a
of an understanding between the citizens
themselves and those that are elected in
office so with that I'll end my
testimony if there's any questions I
will gladly take them thank you to all
representative bur you have a
question yes thank you Mr chair thank
you uh representative and thank you for
your kind words
earlier um using the example of seab
brook let's say C Brook is not having a
teeny weeny leak let's say C Brook is
melting down okay and the Governor even
in your scenario wishes to call the
legislature back to session let's say
that will take 2448 hours is it your
position that the governor should not be
allowed to issue an immediate order
saying nobody shall be within a thousand
feet of seabook as it's spewing forth
radiation um thank you representative
Burch I like for the record I liked your
former background better than this one
but they're both very good
um the background of the state house um
chamber was really cool I can see that
saying that no one would should be
within a thousand feet of Seabrook is
reasonable but back to my example about
the freedom of press I don't think the
governor should be allowed to say well
but the but the union leader can't
report on what's going on because this
could create Mass hysteria I think
having real information provided by an
independent outside private organization
known as The Press whether that's people
on blogs or whether that's newspapers or
Media or TV media I think there's real
value in making sure that if that
everything outlined in the Bill of
Rights is is clearly
protected did I answer your
question um I didn't wasn't really
talking about the media I was talking
about barring individuals I'll give you
the thousand feet he the governor could
clearly call the house and S it into
session immediately um conquered may not
be close or may be too close given your
hypothetical and we have to meet up in I
don't know Brenton Woods and it may take
a week to get that orchestrated but in
that mean same time right I go through
the list of things that are in part 1
Article 1 through 39 and I'm not sure
when I read
these um these protections outlined as
the Bill of Rights right um that we
should be spending any of
them all right thank
you any other
questions see n thank you for your
testimony today thank you
chairman I'm gonna uh just we have two
more people who have signed have their
hands up to testify I just want to say
that I'm I'm I'm going to recess the
hearing briefly at two to
allow um representative Smith just to
address address the next bill because
she has to go to a memorial service this
afternoon and uh I want to let her have
an opportunity to do that and then we'll
come back and finish this hearing as
soon as she does that
okay and the next person to testify is
John
Schmidt you may have to unmute
thank
you Mr Schmid you
there hello Mr
Schmidt uh for some reason I'm showing
them on the screen but but not hearing
anything so what we'll do is we'll go on
to the next witness and come back to Mr
Schmidt the next witness is Mike
Thornton and Mr Thornton can you hear
us yes sir now I can thank you Mr chair
Representatives I'm Mike thoron from
Milford I am a member of New Hampshire
Firearms Coalition a member of pent
Mountain fishing game and go New
Hampshire I speak as a private
citizen I will not speak in
hypotheticals but in absolute historical
fact uh the event was Katrina down
south and the
authorities acting on emergency Powers
went in and disarmed forcefully
disarmed peaceful
people doing nothing but protecting
their own property and not even
brandishing firearms in one famous
instance a little old lady remarked to
an officer that she would be fine she
had a
revolver the officer knocked her to the
ground on TV knocked her to the ground
and forcibly disarmed her she then had
to be
evacuated that this can't be allowed to
happen not in a hypothetical in a in a
situation where civil
Authority is no longer able to protect
the citizens the citizens must not be
presented from protecting
themselves part of that is the first
amendment they have to know what is
happening around them there must be
freedom of speech there must be informed
decisionmaking that's the very
Foundation of our document
that said we the people you take that
away and there is
nobody no
person the house nobody has legitimacy
anymore because it is no longer we the
people and with that I will take
questions and thank you for your
time thank you for your brief testimony
appreciate it are there any questions
for Mr
Thornton seeing none again thank you for
your
testimony
and
um again I'm just going to try Mr
Schmidt and see if Mr Schmidt's
available to speak briefly Mr Schmidt
are you available can you hear us
now Mr Schmidt can you hear
us
doesn't seem to be working is there
anybody else who wanted to test there
are other people so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to recess at this point in
time the hearing on HB 440 and as I said
uh we are scheduled to have a hearing
this afternoon at 2 o'clock on HB
418 and the sponsor of that bill
representative
Smith uh has to go to uh uh will not be
with us much longer and so I'm just
going to let her introduce the bill and
then I'll come back and we'll finish our
hearing on 4:40 so representative Smith
would you like to introduce I'll call
I'll
call um to order House Bill 418 and
representative Smith would you like to
provide your testimony thank you very
much um Mr chair I appreciate your
courtesy um I um am here to introduce
House Bill
418 relative to Supreme Court Reporting
this is a bill that I submitted at the
request of the judicial branch I don't
want to say it's a simple bill or a
housekeeping bill because we all know
when you say that that that makes every
legislator nervous um but what this is
is a bill that acknowledges the changes
that have taken place um in how we keep
records how we share records how we
report records and I cannot be more
pleased to see that it is at least one
example of the third branch of
government wanting to move itself into
the current century or the current
decade sometimes that is a branch that's
a little slow to do do that and that
they are acknowledging changes right now
um I think is something that
shows uh great progress and something
that would be important and valuable for
um state government without in any way
compromising any of the our rights or
access to information all that this bill
does is acknowledge that the system that
was in
La um for
producing uh
documents um might have outlived its
usefulness and its cost is
significant um I I am pleased to see
that for this bill um uh representative
Burch has decided to move from the state
house or a lovely outdoor site to a law
library and he I hope does that to
recognize
that um what this bill does is to um
make it possible to use modern uh means
of technology to distribute information
about the work of the court and I would
ask the committee to support um uh this
legislation that as I say was um
submitted at the request of um of the
judicial branch
thank you Mr
chair thank you are there any questions
oh there is a question representative
bur thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative and Madam chair for
taking my question it'll be very brief
uh as I read the bill at at line 16 it
would allow the Supreme Court to
eliminate these volumes that you see
virtually behind me
and I may be an old traditionalist and
the like
um is that the intent of the bill to say
that these kind of volumes will possibly
no longer be uh uh
published um I I think that that is in
fact a possible alternative if I had
more um skill with zoom I would IM
immediately changed my background to one
of my library to show how I value the
written word and do not value the
absence of a book in my hands but I
would ask um Mr uh chair that um you
might recognize um Lori Platt who is um
here and represented the court who would
be able to I think answer um
representative burch's question with
more accuracy than I
could uh thank you I I'm going to recess
this hearing when you're done speaking
and then we'll come back and finish this
hearing and I definitely will represent
uh will call upon attorney Platt at that
time thank you and again I thank you for
your courtesy and I do apologize for
leaving um the hearing early not a
problem thank than
you okay I'm going to uh recess the
hearing on House Bill
418 uh and having just having had it
introduced by representative Smith and
go back to our hearing on House Bill
440 and I'm gonna try one more time John
Smith to see if we can get him
to
participate Mr Schmidt can you hear us
at all can you speak
uh can you unmute yourself it doesn't
appear that you're muted
but doesn't seem to be
working
and is there anyone else who hasn't
testified on House Bill 440 who wishes
to testify on House Bill
440 it was someone else who appeared to
have their hand up earlier
but I don't see anyone so we'll that's
fine we'll close the hearing on
representative honorable Hull had a
comment to to add in okay
I yes you'd like to be heard again thank
you chairman Gordon um just uh I want to
point out for the record that my my
hypothetical example was an extreme one
because and it was so we should note
that um a melt a meltdown at C Brook is
a serious serious serious issue the most
serious I could think of on the spot so
I would wish that on no one and I just
wanted to make that further record I was
just picking the most extreme example I
could think of for a state of emergency
so thank you everyone thank
you and uh with that I'll declare the
hearing on House Bill 440 closed and go
back and reopen the hearing on House
Bill
48 and call upon Lori Platt to
testify Journey plat are you
there
I don't know what's happening
here don't know if you're muted on your
end perhaps the clerk could try in case
there's some problem on the chair's
end Jen are you there I am um the only
thing I can think of is let's um I'm
going to try to promote her and see if
that makes any difference for
us attorney plat you're unmuted if you
could
speak
is her computer volume all the way down
maybe yeah that's all I can assume is
that there might be a mic problem on her
end there is a mic
connected
oh she's
connecting it says she can obviously
hear us
[Music]
attorney plat it looks like you might be
muted can
you do
you perhaps if if we're not connecting
this way perhaps you could call
in in the meantime is there anybody else
who wishes to speak on this
bill
[Applause]
Mike thoron did you want to speak on
this bill or were you I know you spoke
on the last
bill yes sir Mr chair I I do wish to
speak briefly on this bill as well okay
if you look at George Orwell 1984 the
first first thing they did is they got
rid of the written word so that history
could be changed at any moment and no
one would be the
wiser I'm not
saying
have Tes of useless paper lying around
but there needs to be an immutable trail
that any citizen can
access and rely upon that there is a a
reliable source of any changes to law or
fact for the protection of the entire
public thank you very much thank
you any questions for Mr
Thornton seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today
and um representative Gordon my only
last idea would be um if attorney Platt
happens to have connected by
phone to um raise her hand with star
N I just see one Callin call-in user but
I'm not sure that that is
her
yep there a
h i can try yeah there is that you miss
plat you have to
unmute unmute using star six yeah star
six there we go can you actually hear me
oh thank
you if you just um mute your computer
because we're getting a little
feedback okay now now is it
working yes it's much better perfect
okay thank you very much um first of all
I'd like to thank um representative
Smith for sponsoring the bill um I
believe representative Burch while we
were scrambling to try to unmute me you
asked the question about whether we were
going to do away with printing the
books okay um that may be the goal
eventually but right now what we're
trying to do is make our opinions more
accessible to everyone and so um this
bill would accomplish two things and can
I just discuss one very minor point this
bill would also make the statutes gender
neutral um right now they refer to the
reporter as a he but the other is to
allow the court to move from publishing
its decisions in Bound volumes to having
the ability to publish the official
version online and eventually to have
our the opinions on our website be
searchable um the current intention of
the court is not to do away with
publishing the volumes but you should
know that the demand for published
volumes is going down so and as a result
the price for publishing them is in all
likelihood going to increase as we go
forward um I think it will take some
time to do this uh
certainly I've met with Terry faf and
Scott Kelly because we are kind of we're
hoping to develop some sort of
searchable database much as you have the
bill status search um
capability which you may or may not know
was developed by your own IT staff I
believe
so I do think that eventually we will
not have printed books but that's not
something that I see as happening
immediately yes representative
Sylvia thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question attorney PL
um um previous speaker spoke to uh the
possibility of an an immutable record
and I know that the technology is coming
around with all the blockchain stuff
that goes on is there an intention or a
thought or consideration toward um
assuring that the original source is U
maintained in some fashion where it it
can
be known that it is the
original we actually have a study
committee uh or I gather it's a working
committee with our law librarian who is
looking at that exact issue among many
other issues um so it's definitely uh
something that we is on the our radar so
to speak and it definitely would be
considered uh as we move forward at
perhaps a somewhat glacial Pace thank
you
yes representative D
Lorenzo thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question Miss plat um so
looking at a scenario where the law
books would be no longer published would
the public have access to the online
information I mean free access yes thank
you that is a great question and that is
the goal um you can't the public would
have access and does have access right
now to court opinions but the the
general public cannot search the
opinions on our website so for example
if you were looking for a case involving
uh I guess DUI
convictions if you don't have access to
a commercial search engine you can't
search our opinions and so we'd like to
make the the Court's goal is to make the
opinions on our website the official
version and also at some point to
develop a search engine so that members
of the general public can actually look
at those opinions and find the topic
that they're looking
for thank
you other
[Music]
questions do you have a time frame for
when you think this is going to
happen
um we would hope we would hope that it
has to it really thought to begin at the
beginning of a calendar year just
because there are a number of different
factors that are involved and so if this
bill were to pass we would uh begin
meeting this summer and by January
hopefully uh the goal would be to
declare the opinions on our website as
the official version that doesn't mean
we would stop publishing the New
Hampshire reports I don't see that
happening based on my conversations with
the court a for some time in fact we
have a publication contract uh that
covers the next few volumes of the New
Hampshire report
so that's why the bill is drafted as it
is so that there's an overlap for some
time if I could just follow up on that
so is there a need right now to indicate
that the reports can be either in the
form of the written form or on the
website
form as long as you're authorized to do
it on the
website well we I mean the court would
like to declare that the opinions on the
website are the official
version
[Music]
um so I I'm not sure that I understand
your
question I don't I don't see anything in
here that says that the
reports are the official version
um it just says the reports may be
published either in volumes entitled The
New Hampshire reports or on the Supreme
Court
website so that doesn't seem to be
anything and and so if I read it
actually if I read it literally that
means it can be one or the other but um
I'm presuming that it could be both I
guess there's is
there if we if you give you the
authority to put it on the website it
isn't necessarily making it the official
opinion is
it not not immediately although that
would be our goal as soon as we as soon
I I think that would be the goal uh we
again I don't know how long it's going
to take to develop the search engine
um so section two of the bill talks
about amending RSA 505 colon 8 and the
proposed amendment Rome three would
allow us to publish in volumes as well
as on the Supreme Court website there'll
be an overlap for some period of
time okay any other
questions see none thanks for your
testimony today thank you very much
okay and is there anybody else who
wishes to testify today hasn't had that
opportunity seeing none we close the
hearing on House Bill
418 and is there any other business I I
know for the Republicans we do have a
caucus on Sunday
afternoon from three to
five
and um is there any other business that
we need to take care of
today no thank you all for taking the
time today I know it's been a full week
it's the legislature's become a
full-time job here and I don't know
somebody's mentioned a couple different
people have mentioned the emails but
when I got home last Friday I had over a
thousand emails in my box and I'm sure
you're all getting inundated as
well yes representative Chase yes I was
just wondering if there's a pay raise in
our
future I wouldn't count on it funny well
funny should mention that I'm
co-sponsoring a cacr with rep MC
Williams and the effect of that would be
to uh take out the $100 a year from the
Constitution which time was 12th the
governor's statute and then uh let the
legislature determine it by Statute um
that's an idea that not seem to be met
with much enthusiasm I don't think we
can get past the 60% of the membership
of the house let alone 60% of the Senate
and two-thirds of the people but it's a
it's it's a remote possibility but that
would not take effect for a few years
even if it goes anywhere so can't stay
remote and legislature at the same
sentence yeah I'm I'm taking all of this
as a no I will not see an extra paycheck
no not looking that way and actually
we're we're not getting the mileage
checks this year zooming so that's the
the way it goes
and more work and a cut back yeah got it
and not only that if you're retired and
you have money in the stock market it's
been a very bad week as well I might
ask anyway we'll see you we'll see you
all next Tuesday thank you Mr
sh
great take care ni